Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Custer's life demonstrates the power of a person having fun. Why were his superiors never able to restrain him successfully or to keep this repeat offender away from important commands? Maybe because they secretly looked up to him. Maybe because a career of cavalry charges and danger and glory was something they had dreamed about as boys. Maybe because a career of cavalry charges and danger and glory was something they had dreamed about as boys. Maybe because he more closely resembled the soldier they had dreamed of being than they now did. Or maybe they simply loved him. Custer was good at being loved.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。卡斯特的一生证明了一个人“玩得开心”所带来的力量。为什么他的上级从未能成功约束他，或让这个惯犯远离重要的指挥岗位？也许是因为他们私下里仰慕他。也许是因为骑兵冲锋、危险和荣耀的职业生涯是他们儿时梦想的东西。也许是因为骑兵冲锋、危险和荣耀的职业生涯是他们儿时梦想的东西。也许是因为他比现在的他们更像他们曾经梦想成为的那种士兵。又或者，他们只是单纯地喜爱他。卡斯特很擅长让人喜爱。
Custer's fame is the victory of fun and myth over complicated history. Pursuing his boy's dream of a life on the Great Plains, Custer finally ran into the largest off-reservation gathering of Indians ever in one place on the continent, and gave them what was possibly the last really good time they ever had. So that, Dominic, is from a book that I read when I was roaming the Great Plains. Right, like a bison. Well, yes, or like Custer. And it's by Ian Fraser.
卡斯特的名声是“乐趣”与“神话”战胜复杂历史的胜利。卡斯特追逐着他儿时在大平原生活的梦想，最终遇到了该大陆有史以来规模最大的非保留地印第安人聚会，并给了他们可能是他们有生以来最后一段真正美好的时光。所以，多米尼克，这段话出自我在大平原漫游时读的一本书。没错，就像野牛一样。嗯，是的，或者像卡斯特一样。这本书是伊恩·弗雷泽写的。
And it always stuck in my mind because I wanted to understand the appeal of Custer, the myth of Custer. You know, Ian Fraser is brilliant on Crazy Horse as well, on all the various characters in this story. So in this episode, we're going to see whether that characterisation is true. I mean, I think there are definitely elements of it, but whether, for instance, it was always Custer's dream to end up on the planes,
它一直留在我的脑海里，因为我想了解卡斯特的吸引力，了解卡斯特的神话。你知道，伊恩·弗雷泽在描写“疯马”以及这个故事中所有不同角色方面都非常出色。所以在这集节目中，我们将看看这种描述是否属实。我的意思是，我认为其中肯定有真实的成分，但比如，卡斯特是否一直梦想着最终来到平原，
whether he was really as lovable and charming as he's often made out to be, that is what we're going to be exploring today. Yeah, it's a great introduction actually, Tom, because I think it's wrong. I'm not sure his superiors did love him. I actually think, as we'll discover, quite a lot of his superiors found him incredibly annoying. And as you say, one of the interesting things about Custer is I don't think it is his dream to end up in the Great Plains. I think he wants
他是否真的像人们常说的那样可爱迷人，这就是我们今天要探讨的内容。是的，这确实是一个很好的开场白，汤姆，因为我认为这是错误的。我不确定他的上级是否真的爱他。实际上，正如我们将要发现的那样，他的许多上级觉得他极其令人讨厌。正如你所说，关于卡斯特有趣的一点是，我不认为他的梦想是最终来到大平原。我认为他想
to end up somewhere very different. But I think what is absolutely right is that there is a sense of fun and sort of the swash of a buckle about Custer's story, isn't there? Dash. And that's what we talked about last time. So Custer in the Civil War, obviously the Civil War is quite a dark story, but his role
去一个非常不同的地方。但我认为绝对正确的是，卡斯特的故事中确实有一种乐趣和某种“剑侠”色彩，不是吗？冲劲。这就是我们上次谈到的。所以卡斯特在内战中，显然内战是一个相当黑暗的故事，但他在其中的角色
in it is perceived as being very romantic. He is the great star, the cavalier of the cavalry charge of Gettysburg and of all the campaigns in the Shenandoah Valley and things. And actually in this episode, I think things will turn a little bit darker. And what we'll be seeing today is how the things that happen in this episode, which is in the sort of period after the civil war, there are a lot of sort of foreshadowings here of the events that will lead up to the battle of the little bighorn.
被认为是非常浪漫的。他是伟大的明星，是葛底斯堡骑兵冲锋和谢南多厄河谷所有战役中的骑士。实际上，在这一集中，我认为事情会变得稍微黑暗一些。我们今天将看到这一集中发生的事情（即内战后的时期）是如何为导致小大角战役的事件埋下伏笔的。
So the politics of reconstruction, the war in Mexico with the French, the rift that he has with Ulysses S. Grant. And then in particular, he's involved in this war with the Cheyennes. And there's a series of kind of, I don't know whether battles is the right word. I mean, some people would say massacres, wouldn't they? Well, I mean, this is the joke, isn't it? That when the Americans do it, it's a victory. And when the Indians do it it it's a massacre yes exactly exactly and we will come on to all this won't we and all of these things we're sort of sowing a lot of seeds that will kind of bear fruit towards the end of this series so just on custer i mean you love custer
比如重建时期的政治、墨西哥与法国的战争、他与尤利西斯·S·格兰特之间的裂痕。特别是，他卷入了与夏延人的战争。有一系列，我不知道“战斗”这个词是否合适。我的意思是，有些人会说是“屠杀”，不是吗？嗯，我的意思是，这就是笑话，不是吗？当美国人这样做时，那是胜利；而当印第安人这样做时，那是屠杀。是的，完全正确。我们将谈到所有这些，不是吗？所有这些事情都在播下种子，这些种子将在本系列结束时结出果实。那么，关于卡斯特，我的意思是，你喜欢卡斯特，
don't you well no will you enjoy the myth of custer that's fair to say i do enjoy the myth of custer but i also i mean clearly as we're going to see over the next few episodes and in today's episode, there are some very, very dark aspects to his character. But you can absolutely see that in the wake of the Civil War, which, as you said, was incredibly brutal, harrowing conflict, there would be a popular market for a figure of dash and colour and excitement and who conveys a sense that he had actually enjoyed the whole shebang. Oh, absolutely. I mean, the New York Times, I know we always love the New York Times on this podcast. We do, yeah.
不是吗？嗯，不，你会享受卡斯特的神话。这话说得对，我确实享受卡斯特的神话，但我也——我的意思是，正如我们将在接下来的几集中以及今天的节目中看到的那样，他的性格中确实有一些非常、非常黑暗的方面。但你绝对可以看出，在内战之后——正如你所说，那是一场极其残酷、令人痛苦的冲突——市场上肯定会有对那种充满冲劲、色彩和兴奋感，并且传达出他确实享受了整个过程的人物形象的需求。哦，绝对。我的意思是，《纽约时报》——我知道我们在这个播客里总是很喜欢《纽约时报》。我们确实喜欢，是的。
Called him the very beau ideal of the American cavalry officer. He's a magnificent rider, fearlessly brave, a capital revolver shot, and he's without a single objectionable habit. And that remains the take of the New York Times on Custer to this day. Yes, I think not. Actually, nothing captures this better. So they have a parade at the end of the New York Times on Custer to this day. Yes, I think not. Actually, nothing captures this better. So they have a parade at the end of the Civil War. So this is the 23rd of May, 1865.
称他为美国骑兵军官的“完美典范”。他是一位出色的骑手，无所畏惧，枪法精湛，而且没有任何令人反感的习惯。直到今天，《纽约时报》对卡斯特的评价依然如此。是的，我想不是。实际上，没有什么比这更能说明问题了。所以他们在内战结束时举行了一场游行。这是1865年5月23日。
It's in Washington, D.C. There's a big kind of receiving stand and there's all the senators. Lincoln has been assassinated. So his successor, President Andrew Johnson, is there. And it's the first day, it's the Army of the Potomacs. That's the army that Custer was part of. And he leads the cavalry in the procession. And he's on this stallion that he has actually stolen
地点在华盛顿特区。有一个很大的检阅台，所有的参议员都在那里。林肯遇刺了，所以他的继任者安德鲁·约翰逊总统也在场。这是第一天，是波托马克军团。那是卡斯特所属的军队。他带领骑兵参加了游行。他骑着一匹他实际上偷来的种马，
called Don Juan. Or maybe Don Juan. Maybe Don Juan after Lord Byron, your associate. Well, because you know he has a dog called Byron. So perhaps it is cool. Yeah, who knows? Yeah, who knows? Who knows?
叫“唐璜”。或者可能是“唐璜”。也许是以你的同事拜伦勋爵命名的“唐璜”。因为你知道他有一条狗叫拜伦。所以也许这很酷。是的，谁知道呢？是的，谁知道呢？谁知道呢？
Anyway, he's on this horse and if you read any of the biographies of Custer, they will sort of say, you know, he's the champion, the hero, gallantry incarnate, one of them calls him. You know, he looks splendid on this horse. And he's riding down and like a scene from a medieval tournament,
总之，他骑着这匹马，如果你读过任何关于卡斯特的传记，他们都会说，你知道，他是冠军，是英雄，是英勇的化身，其中一个人这样称呼他。你知道，他骑在马上看起来非常壮观。他骑马走过来，就像中世纪锦标赛中的场景一样，
a young lady throws this bouquet of flowers to him and he catches it with his free hand. Very impressive. And the horse panics and kind of bolts and everybody gasps in horror. It's this shocking moment at the head of the parade. And Custer, basically, he still holds this wreath in one hand while he wrestles with the reins with the other hand and he brings the horse to a halt to the great relief of the excited audience who gave the gallant general three
一位年轻女士向他扔了一束花，他用空着的那只手接住了。非常令人印象深刻。马惊了，开始狂奔，每个人都惊恐地倒吸一口凉气。这是游行队伍最前方令人震惊的一刻。而卡斯特，基本上，他一只手拿着花环，另一只手努力控制缰绳，他让马停了下来，这让兴奋的观众松了一口气，他们给了这位英勇的将军三次
cheers says one of the newspaper reports and there's a torrent of applause and this completely overshadows you know the rest of the parade Custer has done tremendously he's made himself a star well you could say that or you could say say, here he is. Showing off. Showing off. Yeah, totally. And it all goes wrong. Well, I mean, it doesn't go wrong in the long run because the public think it's brilliant. Let me just tell you what, the Harrisburg Weekly Patriot and Union, top newspaper, says.
欢呼，其中一份报纸报道说，掌声如潮，这完全掩盖了游行队伍的其他部分。卡斯特做得非常出色，他让自己成为了明星。嗯，你可以这么说，或者你可以说，看他。在炫耀。在炫耀。是的，完全是。结果一切都搞砸了。嗯，我的意思是，从长远来看并没有搞砸，因为公众认为这很棒。《哈里斯堡周刊爱国者与联盟报》（一份顶级报纸）是这样说的。
Yeah. Says it was like the charge of a Sioux chieftain. The cheers were the involuntary homage of the everyday heart to the man of romance general custer should have lived in a less sordid age yeah and that comparison with the charge of a sioux chieftain that has a very ironic ring doesn't it it does from the post 1876 perspective but again it foreshadows what we were talking about in the previous episode that there are kind of weird parallels between Custer and particularly Crazy Horse, the extraordinary commander he'll face at the Little Bighorn.
是的。说这就像苏族酋长的冲锋。欢呼声是普通民众对这位浪漫英雄的自发敬意。卡斯特本应生活在一个不那么肮脏的时代。是的，那个与苏族酋长冲锋的比较，听起来非常有讽刺意味，不是吗？确实，从1876年后的视角来看是这样。但同样，它预示了我们在上一集中谈到的内容，即卡斯特与他将在小大角面对的非凡指挥官“疯马”之间存在某种奇怪的相似之处。
There are indeed. Particularly to do with their hair, I believe, Tom. Yeah, it's a hair, but we're also now seeing, aren't we, his ability to charge on a horse. Yes. So it's all stacking up. So the question is, what's Custer going to do after the war? The first thing that happens is he ends up being sent to Texas with his sort of patron, General Sheridan, who we talked about last time. Very short man, very fierce. Little Phil. Yeah. And they've been sent to Texas for two reasons. One,
确实如此。特别是关于他们的头发，我相信是这样，汤姆。是的，是头发，但我们现在也看到了，不是吗，他骑马冲锋的能力。是的。所以这一切都在堆积。所以问题是，战后卡斯特会做什么？发生的第一件事是他最终被派往德克萨斯，跟随他的赞助人谢里登将军，我们上次谈到过他。个子很矮，非常凶猛。“小菲尔”。是的。他们被派往德克萨斯有两个原因。第一，
Texas had actually never been conquered by Union armies. So slavery up to this point has been very much in force in Texas and they have to basically impose their control. But also they're very anxious about Mexico. So there's a war in Mexico, as we talked about in an episode of The Rest of History a long time ago. Yeah. A friend of the show, Maximilian. Yeah. The Emperor Maximilian, the brother of the Austrian Emperor Franz Josef, has been installed by Napoleon III as Emperor of Mexico. There's an uprising against him. The Americans are very anxious about this. They want a strong Union army presence in Texas on the other side of the border. They send Custer, and he has a terrible time in Texas. Basically, he's very good at cavalry charges, but he is terrible at managing men when they have nothing to do, isn't he? He's just a
德克萨斯实际上从未被联邦军队征服过。所以到目前为止，奴隶制在德克萨斯仍然非常盛行，他们基本上必须强加控制。但他们也非常担心墨西哥。所以墨西哥有一场战争，正如我们在很久以前的一集《历史的余味》中谈到的那样。是的。节目的朋友，马克西米利安。是的。奥地利皇帝弗朗茨·约瑟夫的弟弟马克西米利安皇帝，被拿破仑三世扶植为墨西哥皇帝。针对他的起义正在发生。美国人对此非常焦虑。他们希望在边境另一侧的德克萨斯有强大的联邦军队驻扎。他们派出了卡斯特，他在德克萨斯过得很糟糕。基本上，他非常擅长骑兵冲锋，但在无事可做时管理手下却非常糟糕，不是吗？他只是一个
bad man manager. He's a bad middle manager. You need a good man behind a desk. Well, he's all about charging. Yeah. And if you're just sitting around in barracks, there are no opportunities for charging. Although, as we will see, Custer is quite good at manufacturing opportunities for dashing around. He is. So the other issue that starts to be apparent now, and this, by the way, is going to be important all the way through to the end of this series, the end of Custer's life. Custer is politically not on the same page as many of his associates and his superior officers. So people who heard the first
糟糕的人事经理。他是一个糟糕的中层管理者。你需要一个坐在办公桌后的人。嗯，他满脑子都是冲锋。是的。如果你只是坐在军营里，就没有冲锋的机会。尽管正如我们将要看到的，卡斯特非常擅长制造四处冲锋的机会。他确实是。所以现在开始显现的另一个问题是——顺便说一句，这将贯穿本系列的始终，直到卡斯特生命的尽头——卡斯特在政治上与他的许多同事和上级军官并不一致。所以听过第一集的人，
episode, which I hope is everybody, will remember that he was a Democrat and that he was actually before the war, he was very kind of sympathetic to the South. Now we're into the period called Reconstruction, where it's basically slavery has been abolished. What are you going to do with all the formerly enslaved people? Are you going to give them something? Are they going to be equal citizens? What's going to happen to them? And what's going to happen to the old Confederates and the government of the South? And there are some people, radical Republicans as they're called, including his patron General Sheridan, who are much more, you know, they're kind of hardline against the southerners.
我希望是所有人，都会记得他是一名民主党人，而且在战前，他实际上非常同情南方。现在我们进入了所谓的“重建时期”，基本上奴隶制已经被废除了。你打算怎么处理所有以前被奴役的人？你要给他们什么吗？他们会成为平等的公民吗？他们会发生什么？旧的邦联分子和南方政府会发生什么？有些人，所谓的“激进共和党人”，包括他的赞助人谢里登将军，他们更——你知道，他们对南方人采取强硬路线。
They're like, these people are rebels, they're racists, they're white supremacists, you know, through force, we will institute a new order. And then there are people like Custer who are just, you know, let's all be friends again. Actually, who cares about all the freed slaves? You know, I don't really, yeah, my heart doesn't bleed. That's what Custer thinks. My heart doesn't bleed. That's what Custer thinks. His heart doesn't bleed for them. Because as we said in the last episode,
他们说，这些人是叛军，是种族主义者，是白人至上主义者，你知道，通过武力，我们将建立一种新的秩序。然后还有像卡斯特这样的人，他们只是，你知道，让我们重新做朋友吧。实际上，谁在乎那些被解放的奴隶呢？你知道，我真的不——是的，我的心不会为他们流血。这就是卡斯特的想法。我的心不会为他们流血。这就是卡斯特的想法。他的心不会为他们流血。因为正如我们在上一集中所说，
you know, he's friends with lots of these Confederate officers. He was at West Point with them. He is exactly right. His father, Emmanuel, who's obviously a massive influence on him, is exceedingly racist. You know, there's a lot of sort of banter, which I won't repeat, about black dolls, black babies, all this kind of stuff. He's always making racist jokes.
你知道，他和许多这些邦联军官是朋友。他和他们一起在西点军校。他完全正确。他的父亲伊曼纽尔，显然对他有巨大的影响，是一个极其种族主义的人。你知道，有很多那种——我不会重复——关于黑人玩偶、黑人婴儿等等的玩笑。他总是开种族主义玩笑。
Custer's wife, Libby, when they go to Texas, she gets right in with the kind of Texas planter classes. You know, she's like going to balls and wearing a big dress and sipping mint juleps. Vivian Leung around and all that. Yeah, Vivian Leying, exactly. And she says, and I quote, the Negroes in Texas and Louisiana were the worst in all the South. Her letters betray the extent of her prejudice. So the Custers have a very miserable time in Texas because he's basically being told you have to impose the new law and he doesn't like it. So then he leaves Texas in early 1866. He's a bit of a loose end. Now, most biographers say, you know, this is just a hiatus in his career.
卡斯特的妻子利比，当他们去德克萨斯时，她很快就融入了德克萨斯的种植园主阶层。你知道，她去参加舞会，穿着大礼服，啜饮薄荷朱利酒。到处闲逛之类的。是的，薇薇安·莱，完全正确。她说，我引用一下，“德克萨斯和路易斯安那的黑人是整个南方最糟糕的。”她的信件暴露了她偏见的程度。所以卡斯特夫妇在德克萨斯过得很悲惨，因为他基本上被告知必须执行新法律，而他并不喜欢这样。所以他在1866年初离开了德克萨斯。他有点无所事事。现在，大多数传记作者说，你知道，这只是他职业生涯中的一个间歇。
Who knows what to make of Custer here? His most recent biography, T.J. Stiles is brilliant on this. He says, actually, this is the period that most clearly reveals Custer's true self. It was a time when he pursued some of his deepest interests and indulged in some of his greatest pleasures. And actually what he wants to do, he basically wants to reinvent himself as a New Yorker, as a New York tycoon. So in other words, it's not his dream to go to the Great Plains. No. It's his dream to hobnob with plutocrats. Totally is. What's so great about this, Tom, is if if he had lived he'd have been first on the titanic wouldn't he yeah he'd have loved it yeah because all the kind of people that he
谁知道该怎么看待这里的卡斯特呢？他最近的传记作者T.J.斯泰尔斯对此有精彩的论述。他说，实际上，这是最能揭示卡斯特真实自我的时期。那是一个他追求自己最深层的兴趣并沉溺于自己最大乐趣的时期。实际上他想做的是，他基本上想把自己重塑为一个纽约人，一个纽约大亨。所以换句话说，去大平原并不是他的梦想。不。他的梦想是与财阀们交际。完全是。汤姆，这最棒的地方在于，如果他活着，他会是第一批登上泰坦尼克号的人，不是吗？是的，他会喜欢的。是的，因为他交往的所有那些人
hangs around with are very much sort of titanic first class passenger people well he's hanging out with the asters isn't he the asters i long to become wealthy he writes to his wife not for wealth alone but for the power that it brings okay and so when he's talking about that power you know there's talk as we will see that he attacks the Native American encampment in the way that he does, because he wants the news of it to reach New York in time for the centenary of independence. Yeah. And thereby give himself a leg up for the presidency. Do you think at this point, when he talks about power, is he thinking about political power or is he thinking just about financial power? I think he loves dabbling in politics and he does it again and again in this episode
基本上都是泰坦尼克号头等舱乘客那样的人。嗯，他和阿斯特家族混在一起，不是吗？阿斯特家族。我渴望变得富有，他写信给妻子，不是为了财富本身，而是为了它带来的权力。好的，所以当他谈到那种权力时，你知道，有传言说，正如我们将要看到的，他以那种方式攻击美洲原住民营地，是因为他希望关于这件事的消息能及时传到纽约，赶上独立百年纪念。是的。从而为自己竞选总统提供助力。你认为在这一点上，当他谈到权力时，他是在考虑政治权力，还是仅仅在考虑经济权力？我认为他喜欢涉足政治，而且他在这一集
and subsequent episodes. He can't stop himself, even when it's extremely damaging to his military career. He's always interested in politics. He's one of those people who will bore about it later night, I think. I think it's social status as much as anything. As you said, he loves hanging out with John Jacob Astor III. He goes to Wall Street and the brokers will give him six cheers and he makes remarks from the president's chair in the stock exchange. He loves all that. He is from a small town, nothing town in Ohio. And then he spent time in this other little town
和随后的几集中一次又一次地这样做。他无法阻止自己，即使这对他的军事生涯极其有害。他总是对政治感兴趣。他属于那种会在深夜里喋喋不休谈论政治的人，我想。我认为这更多是关于社会地位。正如你所说，他喜欢和约翰·雅各布·阿斯特三世混在一起。他去华尔街，经纪人们会为他欢呼三次，他在证券交易所的总统椅上发表评论。他喜欢这一切。他来自俄亥俄州一个名不见经传的小镇。然后他在密歇根州的另一个小镇待过。
in Michigan. He's just a boy from nowhere. And I think he likes the company of millionaires. And I think it's the combination of the money, the attention, the fame, and politics is part of that. But I don't think it's his single driving thing. What's so interesting, when he's in New York, he goes to see a clairvoyant. Did you see this? The story about the fortune teller? She's useless. She says, you'll have four children. You'll live to old age and die of natural causes. She tells him what he wants to hear because he writes to Libby afterwards. He says, I was always fortunate since the hour of my birth and always would be.
他只是一个来自无名之地的男孩。我认为他喜欢百万富翁的陪伴。我认为这是金钱、关注、名声的结合，而政治是其中的一部分。但我不认为这是他唯一的驱动力。最有趣的是，当他在纽约时，他去见了一位灵媒。你看到了吗？关于算命先生的故事？她没用。她说，你会生四个孩子。你会长寿，死于自然原因。她告诉他他想听的话，因为他后来写信给利比。他说，我从出生那一刻起就一直很幸运，而且永远都会如此。
My guardian angel has clung to my side since the day I left the cradle. This is the gibberish that the fortune teller is giving him. And then she says, you're clearly thinking about going into one of two things railroads or mining and casta says unbelievable absolutely right but does she also say dominic you'll be going on a journey of course and made a dark stranger yeah no but i mean because he is about to go on a journey isn't he he is about to go on a journey well what he wants to do he about to go on a journey. Well, what he wants to do, he wants to go to Mexico. And fight against Maximilian. Fight against the Emperor Maximilian. And Ulysses S. Grant actually writes him a reference.
我的守护天使从我离开摇篮的那天起就一直守护在我身边。这就是算命先生给他的胡言乱语。然后她说，你显然在考虑从事两件事之一：铁路或采矿。卡斯特说，不可思议，完全正确。但她有没有说，多米尼克，你将踏上一段旅程？当然，还有一个黑衣陌生人。是的，不，但我的意思是，因为他正要踏上一段旅程，不是吗？他正要踏上一段旅程。嗯，他想做的是，他想去墨西哥。对抗马克西米利安。对抗马克西米利安皇帝。尤利西斯·S·格兰特实际上为他写了一封推荐信。
A very fine cavalry officer, splendid Spanish, would fit in very nicely in the world of Mexico. But actually, the American Secretary of State says, we can't send such a well-known person. It's diplomatically a very, very bad move. Annoy the French. So they actually say, well, we'll't send such a well-known person. You know, it's diplomatically a very, very bad move. Annoy the French. So they actually say, well, we'll send him to Kansas. He's going to get a post to Kansas, which is very disappointing, I think,
一位非常优秀的骑兵军官，西班牙语说得很棒，会非常适合墨西哥的世界。但实际上，美国国务卿说，我们不能派这样一个知名人士去。这在外交上是一个非常、非常糟糕的举动。会惹恼法国人。所以他们实际上说，好吧，我们派他去堪萨斯。他会被派往堪萨斯，我认为这非常令人失望，
if you've been toying with a Mexican. Yeah, I mean, hanging out with the Astors. Yeah, you've been hanging out with the Astors. And then he thought about going on a Mexican holiday. No, you're actually going to Kansas? Yeah, with apologies to all our listeners in kansas of course of course but before then you see he still can't stop himself self-destructively dabbling in politics so at the end of 1866 president andrew johnson who had succeeded lincoln who's from
如果你一直在考虑墨西哥的话。是的，我的意思是，和阿斯特家族混在一起。是的，你一直在和阿斯特家族混在一起。然后他想去墨西哥度假。不，你实际上要去堪萨斯？是的，当然，向我们在堪萨斯的所有听众道歉。当然，当然。但在那之前，你看他仍然无法阻止自己，在政治上进行自我毁灭式的涉足。所以1866年底，接替林肯的安德鲁·约翰逊总统，他来自
tennessee and he's very very unsound tom on reconstructionconstruction, Andrew Johnson, because he basically wants to bring Reconstruction to an end. He's a bit racist. He wants to, you know, just make friends with all the old Confederates and stuff. So he's basically, I mean, he is Custer only president. Kind of, yeah. And he's bizarrely campaigning against his own administration. And he launches this unprecedented campaign. No president has ever done this before.
田纳西州，他在重建问题上非常、非常不稳妥，汤姆。安德鲁·约翰逊，因为他基本上想结束重建。他有点种族主义。他想，你知道，只是和所有旧的邦联分子交朋友之类的。所以他基本上——我的意思是，他就是总统版的卡斯特。有点像，是的。而且他奇怪地在反对他自己的政府。他发起了这场前所未有的运动。以前从来没有总统这样做过。
In the midterm elections, it's called the swing around the circle. And he goes and he campaigns violently against the most sort of radical Republicans. And Custer goes with him. Custer is on the platform with him. He's shouting at hecklers. He's giving speeches. And a lot of the other officers, including, indeed, especially Ulysses S. Grant, basically the Supreme Commander of the Army, they are really perturbed by this. This is really bad form from Custer. And it turns them against Custer. And that will be really important later that Grant thinks that Custer is basically an attention seeker, unreliable, and politically totally unsound and on the wrong side. And so when he gets posted to Kansas, is that an exile? And is it meant to be seen as an exile?
在中期选举中，这被称为“环形巡回演讲”。他去那里猛烈抨击最激进的共和党人。卡斯特和他一起去了。卡斯特和他站在同一个平台上。他对着抗议者大喊大叫。他在发表演讲。许多其他军官，包括，确实，特别是尤利西斯·S·格兰特，基本上是军队的最高指挥官，他们对此感到非常不安。卡斯特这样做真的很不妥。这让他们反对卡斯特。这在以后会非常重要，因为格兰特认为卡斯特基本上是一个寻求关注的人，不可靠，在政治上完全不稳妥，站在了错误的一边。所以当他被派往堪萨斯时，那是一种流放吗？这被视为一种流放吗？
Do you think? That's a really good question. I think it definitely is an exile. It definitely is an exile. Is it meant to be punishment? No, because he's posted to Kansas even before he's splotted his copy book politically. So I don't think it's a penalty. But I think it's a really miserable outcome for Custer. Not, we hasten to say, for the benefit of listeners in Kansas, because... God, you're very anxious about those Kansans. Fine people of Kansas.
你觉得呢？这是一个非常好的问题。我认为这绝对是一种流放。这绝对是一种流放。这被视为惩罚吗？不，因为他在政治上搞砸之前就被派往堪萨斯了。所以我不认为这是一种惩罚。但我认为这对卡斯特来说是一个非常悲惨的结果。我们赶紧声明，不是为了堪萨斯的听众，因为……天哪，你对那些堪萨斯人非常焦虑。堪萨斯的好人民。
But because it's an awful place to be a soldier, specifically, right? Yeah. So what has happened is that the Union army has been cut to the bone. It's under enormous pressure because of the task of reconstruction. They've had to put lots of kind of garrisons in the South. But reconstruction's critics are busy attacking the army and saying it's wasteful and it's a drain on the economy. Of course, that's a way of kind of preserving their own power, the power of the white supremacists in the South by attacking the army. Troop numbers generally in
但因为作为一个士兵，那里是一个糟糕的地方，对吧？是的。所以发生的事情是，联邦军队被削减到了骨子里。由于重建的任务，他们承受着巨大的压力。他们不得不在南方驻扎大量的驻军。但重建的批评者正忙着攻击军队，说它浪费，是经济的负担。当然，这是一种通过攻击军队来维护他们自己权力的方式，即南方白人至上主义者的权力。军队人数通常在
this period fall by about half. So what's left is a real rump. And if you stay in the army, it's seen as very much not a great option, really, unless you're at the very top of it. The people who are left in the army, the people that Custer is now associating with, I think by most accounts are just terrible. Yeah. Peter Cousins, who's a very distinguished historian of the Indian wars, he says, not all of the soldiers were bummers and loafers, as the New York Sun alleged. There were also a disproportionately large number of urban poor criminals, drunkards and perverts. Well, that's good to know. So lots of them are illiterate. Most of them are untrained. So there's a lot of conversation in all the historiography about the Indian Wars,
这一时期减少了大约一半。所以剩下的只是一小部分。如果你留在军队里，这被认为不是一个很好的选择，除非你处于最顶层。留在军队里的人，卡斯特现在交往的那些人，我认为大多数说法都只是糟糕。是的。彼得·考辛斯，一位非常杰出的印第安战争历史学家，他说，并非所有的士兵都是流浪汉和懒汉，正如《纽约太阳报》所声称的那样。其中还有数量不成比例的城市贫民罪犯、酒鬼和变态。嗯，很高兴知道这一点。所以他们中的许多人是文盲。他们大多数人未经训练。所以关于印第安战争的所有史学中有很多讨论，
about whether they have enough guns or whether they have the right guns. Peter Cousin says, doesn't matter whether they had guns or not, because they didn't know how to use them. You know, they'd fire them and they'd hold them backwards and they'd go off the wrong way and stuff. But they're not completely useless. They're pretty useless. But there are quite a lot of people of kind of slight Foreign Legion quality to it.
关于他们是否有足够的枪支，或者他们是否有正确的枪支。彼得·考辛斯说，他们是否有枪并不重要，因为他们不知道如何使用它们。你知道，他们会开火，然后把枪拿反了，结果打偏了之类的。但他们并非完全没用。他们相当没用。但确实有很多人有一种轻微的“外籍军团”素质。
Yeah, totally. So there's an old Etonian, isn't there, who ends up shot feathered. Mr. Williams, I think his name is. Isn't it something like that? Williams with a Y, bizarrely. Yes. I'm not saying that Etonians are necessarily brilliant soldiers, but there are people who go there consciously wanting to sign up from abroad.
是的，完全是。所以有一个老伊顿公学毕业生，不是吗，最后被涂上焦油和羽毛。威廉姆斯先生，我想他叫这个名字。不是类似这样的吗？威廉姆斯，带个Y，奇怪的是。是的。我不是说伊顿公学毕业生一定是出色的士兵，但确实有人自觉地想从国外报名参加。
And they're the ones that are good. So they're kind of Italians and... Yeah. If you actually look at the 7th Cavalry in 1876, the year of the little bighorn, a huge proportion of them came from Germany, more than a tenth. About a fifth of them came from Ireland.
而他们是那些优秀的人。所以他们有点像意大利人……是的。如果你看看1876年（小大角战役那年）的第7骑兵团，很大一部分人来自德国，超过十分之一。大约五分之一的人来自爱尔兰。
There were Canadians, Danes, Swiss, French, Italians, Swedes, Norwegians, Spaniards, Greeks, Poles, Hungarians, and Russians. So basically, the image that you have of the 7th Cavalry, which is kind of- All American boys. It's just not right. Yeah. It's basically the dregs of society, without sounding too harsh, like a columnist from
还有加拿大人、丹麦人、瑞士人、法国人、意大利人、瑞典人、挪威人、西班牙人、希腊人、波兰人、匈牙利人和俄罗斯人。所以基本上，你对第7骑兵团的印象，即那种——全都是美国小伙子。这根本不对。是的。这基本上是社会的渣滓，如果不听起来太刺耳的话，就像《每日快报》的专栏作家一样，还有波兰人和德国人等等。还有伊顿公学毕业生。还有伊顿公学毕业生，完全正确。他们生活在最可怕的条件下。谢尔曼将军，他不得不对他们的条件做一份报告，他说基本上你可以把军队的条件当作广告，来展示南方奴隶主的残忍，对吧？他们的条件太糟糕了，他们的制服是垃圾，他们的枪经常不能用，每个人都说他们待在这些堡垒里，他们把所有时间都花在喝酒、赌博和找妓女上，还有那些所谓的营地洗衣妇，
the Daily Express, and Poles and Germans and all this kind of thing. And Etonians. And Etonians, exactly. They live in the most horrendous conditions. General Sherman, who had to do a report on their conditions said basically you could use the army conditions as an advert to show the cruelty of slaveholders in the south right they are such terrible conditions their uniforms are rubbish their guns often don't work everybody says they're in these forts they spend all their time drinking gambling and visiting prostitutes and these sort of camp lawn dresses
她们也兼职做……夜间女士。嗯，是的。埃文·康奈尔在他的书中说，西部并不沉闷，它是极其沉闷的，当不沉闷时，它是致命的。所以，是的，听起来很棒，并不出色。但他确实说，他们有办法让生活变得更有趣。所以其中一个，我觉得听起来确实很有趣，就是他们挑起红蚂蚁和黑蚂蚁群落之间的战斗。好的。我想知道那会通向哪里。所以你会喜欢那个。是的。
who double up as um ladies of the night as well well yes evan connell in his book says the west was not dull it was stupendously dull and when not dull it was murderous so yeah sounds great not brilliant but he does say that there are ways for them to spice things up so one of them which i thought did sound fun was that they provoke fights between colonies of red and black ants. Okay. I wonder where that was going. So you'd enjoy that. Yeah.
我的意思是，我并不是特别喜欢斗蚂蚁。嗯，那么关于洗衣妇的话题。是的。有一个臭名昭著的场合，一位纳什夫人。是的。非常受欢迎的人物。不仅仅是洗衣妇。她还是个护士。萨迪，我的妻子，
I mean, I'm not massively into ant baiting. Well, so on the topic of laundresses. Yes. There was a notorious occasion when a Mrs. Nash. Yeah. Very popular figure. Not just a laundress. She was a nurse. Sadie, my wife,
听到她也是一位非常好的助产士会很兴奋。但她总是戴着面纱，经常被描述为看起来相当古怪。哦，不，这要通向哪里？总之，她嫁给了这个家伙。婚礼后的第二天，那个家伙被看到脸色苍白，然后他逃跑了。又嫁给了这个叫努南的家伙。他们是非常幸福的夫妻。你知道，他们看起来是非常满足的一对。然后纳什夫人病得非常、非常重，去世了。
will be thrilled to hear that she was a very good midwife as well. But she invariably wore a veil and was often described as being rather peculiar looking. Oh no, where's this going? And anyway, she marries this guy. The guy, the day after the wedding, is seen looking ashen-faced, and then he deserts. Marries again to this guy called Noonan. They are very happily married. You know, they seem very contented couple. And then Mrs. Nash is very, very ill and dies.
我想她现在是努南夫人了。当她快死的时候，她说，你知道，请不要处理我的尸体。就把我扔进沟里。好的。你知道，他们不会那样做的。所以他们给了她应有的所有尊重，然后他们发现她是个男人。哇。努南先生对此作何感想？努南先生说他根本不知道。所以他的一个朋友说，我一直想知道为什么你们不打算要孩子。然后接下来的一周，他开枪自杀了。
I suppose she's Mrs. Noonan by now. And as she's dying, she says, you know, please don't tend to my body. Just throw me in a ditch. Okay. You know, they're not going to do that. So they pay her all the respects that are due her, and they find that she's a man. Wow. What did Mr. Noonan make of it? Mr. Noonan says he'd had no idea. So one of his friends says, I'd always wondered why you weren't going to have children. And then the following week he shoots himself.
他开枪自杀了？是的。天哪。所以你认为他一直都知道吗？谁知道呢，多米尼克？谁知道呢？这是历史的不可知因素之一。我的意思是，这就是让生活变得有趣的事情，我想。在边境上？是的。卡斯特会发现这一点。不，卡斯特根本不会赞同这一点。我不知道卡斯特有多进步。
He shoots himself? Yeah. Crikey. So did he know all along, do you think? Who knows, Dominic? Who knows? It's one of the imponderables of history. I mean, that's the kind of thing that's spicing life up, I guess. On the frontier? Yeah. Custer would find that. No, Custer wouldn't approve of that at all. I don't know how progressive Custer is.
但关于卡斯特的话题，我想，我的意思是，我认为他有把坏事变好事的才能。是的。我认为这就是为什么，你知道，伊恩·弗雷泽对他作为一个有能力“玩得开心”的人的描述是完全正确的。所以他带着很多动物。所以他有很多狗。所以我们提到了拜伦，但这只是众多狗中的一只。他被它们包围着，他用狩猎号角之类的东西训练它们。当他在林肯堡时，那是哪里？那是在达科他，
But on the topic of Custer, I think, I mean, I think he has a talent for making the best of a bad job. Yeah. And I think that that's where, you know, Ian Fraser's description of him as a man who is capable of having fun is absolutely true. So he has lots of animals with him. So he has lots of dogs. So we mentioned Byron, but this is just one of lots. He's surrounded by them and he trains them using hunting horns and all this kind of thing. And when he's at Fort Lincoln, where's that? That's in Dakota,
不是吗？他的动物园里大约有40只狗、一只鹈鹕、一只有时睡在卡斯特夫妇床上的豪猪，以及其他各种野生或半野生的东西。当需要去工作时，他认为没有理由剥夺自己带上宠物猎鹿犬的权利。所以基本上，无论他去哪里，他都被这些狗包围着。他利用它们随时去打猎。所以他到达了西部，他进行了这次疯狂的野牛狩猎。他带着手下出去。他们进入荒野。他突然看到一头野牛，就冲了过去。
isn't it? His menagerie consisted of about 40 dogs, a pelican, a porcupine that sometimes slept on the customarital bed, as well as various other wild or half-wild things. And he saw no reason to deprive himself of his pet staghounds when it was time to go to work. And so basically, wherever he's going, he's surrounded by these dogs. And he uses them to kind of go hunting whenever he wants. So he's arrived in the West and he goes on this insane buffalo hunt. He's taking his men out. They're going out into the wilds. He suddenly sees a buffalo, goes careering off.
没人知道他去了哪里。他最终在瞄准野牛时把自己的马射中了头部。他骑在野牛旁边，瞄准步枪，把自己的马射中了头部。这充分说明了野牛的能力。我知道，但这都是乐趣。不是马的乐趣。野牛冲走了。是的。
Nobody knows where he's gone. He ends up shooting his horse through the head while he's aiming at the buffalo. He's riding alongside the buffalo, aims his rifle, shoots his horse through the head. That speaks volumes about the ability of the buffalo. I know, but it's all fun. Not with the horse. The buffalo goes charging off. Yeah.
马死了。他被敌对的——无论是谁，夏延人——包围了，他不知道该怎么办。但你还记得灵媒说了什么吗？他总是很幸运。是的。他走在，你知道，他只是掷了一枚硬币，决定去哪里，朝着那个方向走去，又遇到了第7骑兵团。是的。
The horse is dead. He's surrounded by hostile whoever, Cheyenne, and he doesn't know what he's going to do. But you remember what the clairvoyant said? He's always lucky. Yeah. He walks in a, you know, he just flicks a coin, decides where he's going to go, heads off in that direction and runs into the seventh cavalry again. Yeah.
幸运。幸运的将军。所以这就是他的一切。他还非常热衷于，他制作动物标本，不是吗？他确实是。所以他喜欢动物，无论是活着的还是做成标本的。是的。因为你在我们做的一集关于猴子的节目中说过，你想看到伊恩·博瑟姆
Lucky. Lucky general. So that's what he's all about. He's also very keen on, he stuffs animals, doesn't he? He does. So he's fond of animals, whether they're living or whether they're stuffed. Yeah. Because you were saying in an episode we did about monkeys, you'd like to see Ian Botham
做成标本。还记得吗？我有吗？是的。你说他喜欢把伊恩·博瑟姆做成标本，放在汤顿。萨默塞特，我有吗？我不知道。你说他喜欢把伊恩·博瑟姆做成标本，放在汤顿。萨默塞特。我有吗？我不知道。
stuffed. Remember that? Did I? Yeah. You said he likes to stuff Ian Botham and puts him in Taunton. Somerset, did I? I don't know. You said he likes to stuff Ian Botham and puts him in Taunton. Somerset. Did I? I don't know.
抱歉，这是一个巨大的转折。那是一个巨大的转折。我没想到会进行那样的对话。但他会和卡斯特相处得非常好。我认为伊恩·博瑟姆是一种卡斯特式的人物。我的意思是，在很多方面，他们是同一个人。是的。不是吗？
Sorry, that's a massive segue. That is a massive segue. I wasn't expecting to go down that conversational. But he would have got on terrifically with Custer. I think Ian Botham is a kind of Custer figure. I mean, in many ways, they're the same person. Yeah. Aren't they?
总之，并不是每个人都喜欢卡斯特，汤姆。所以你喜欢他。伊恩·博瑟姆会喜欢他。但一个叫弗雷德里克·本廷的人鄙视他。这非常重要。所以弗雷德里克·本廷，我的意思是，他看起来很奇怪，不是吗？他看起来像贺曼贺卡上的人，我想。你觉得，我认为他看起来像伊灵喜剧中一位备受喜爱的性格演员在扮演一位老处女姑妈。
Anyway, not everybody likes Custer though, Tom. So you like him. Ian Botham would like him. But a man called Frederick Benteen despises him. And this is very important. So Frederick Benteen, I mean, he looks quite odd, doesn't he? He looks like a man from a Hallmark greetings card, I think. Do you think, I think he looks like someone from a much-loved character actor in an Ealing
是的，我能看出来。他看起来像一个在“U-Tree行动”中被带走的人，实际上。如果你不是英国人，你得去谷歌一下。所以他，一位传记作者称他为“面容柔和但痛苦的人”。纳撒尼尔·菲尔布里克对本廷上尉有一幅非常好的肖像。他说，本廷有一种轻松的南方健谈，但在他那胖乎乎的亲切感下，潜藏着一种阴郁、极其愤世嫉俗的智慧。他那冰蓝色的眼睛一眼就能看出一个人内心最深处的自卑，并不可避免地发现他或她有所欠缺。而卡斯特绝不是他贬低和鄙视的唯一指挥官。多米尼克，这听起来非常熟悉。胖乎乎的亲切感。是的，我没有冰蓝色的眼睛。阴郁、极其愤世嫉俗的智慧。得了吧。太可怕了。
comedy playing a maiden aunt. Yes, I can see that. He looks like a man being led away in Operation U-Tree to me, actually. You'll have to Google that if you're not British. So he, one biographer calls him a soft-faced but bitter man. Nathaniel Philbrick has a very nice portrait of Captain Bentine. He says, Bentine had an easy southern volubility about him, but lurking beneath his
所以在这个类比中你是卡斯特，是吗？这就是你的……？是的。不断地被背后捅刀子。是的，当你制作动物标本时。把你的马射中头部。无辜地猎杀野牛。这都很有趣。
chubby cheeked cordiality was a brooding utterly cynical intelligence his icy blue eyes saw at a glance a person's darkest insecurities and inevitably found him or her wanting and custer was by no means the only commander he had belittled and despised. Dominic, this is sounding very familiar. Chubby cheek cordiality. Yeah, I don't have icy blue eyes. Brooding, utterly cynical intelligence. Come on. Terrifying.
本廷鄙视卡斯特。关于这一点，重要的事情有两点。第一，我们所知道的关于卡斯特最后日子、最后时刻的很多信息都来自本廷。第二，本廷在小大角战役中扮演了绝对关键的角色。而且一直有猜测。如果本廷做出了不同的选择，卡斯特可能会活到1877年。所以本廷从这一点开始就恨他，
So you're Custer in this analogy, are you? Is that what you're? Yeah. Constantly being stabbed in the back. Yeah, while you're stuffing your animals. Shooting your horse in the head. Innocently hunting buffalo. It's all great fun.
顺便说一句，他也绝对厌恶卡斯特的妻子，这将是非常、非常重要的。所以更广阔的图景，就在我们进入休息之前，更广阔的图景是他们被派往那里是因为与夏延人即将发生的冲突。所以这些是游牧的、高平原的美洲原住民、印第安人，无论你喜欢用什么术语。当我们告诉他们时，我们可能会非常不一致。每当对这些事情有任何疑问时，我们只是使用所有可能的排列组合。嗯，我想是这样，美洲原住民显然是今天倾向于使用的短语，是的，但当人们
Benteen despises Custer. And the important thing about this is it's twofold. Number one, a lot of what we know about Custer's final days, final hours, comes from Benteen. And number two, Benteen plays an absolutely crucial role in the Battle of the Little Bighorn. And there was always speculation. If Benteen had an absolutely crucial role in the Battle of the Little Bacorn. And there was always speculation. If Benteen had made different choices, Mike Custer would have lived to see 1877. So the fact that Benteen hates him from this point,
在19世纪谈论他们时，他们倾向于使用“平原印第安人”，完全正确，是的。所以我们将在那两者之间滑行。我们将，我们绝对会在下一集中更笼统地谈论当时所谓的“平原印第安人”的背景。所以我们现在不会深入探讨那个，但只是为了让我们对夏延人有一个了解。夏延人最初来自明尼苏达州的森林。他们向南和向西移动，进入了蒙大拿州、怀俄明州、达科他州（正如它们后来成为的那样），最南端到达科罗拉多州和堪萨斯州，甚至俄克拉荷马州。
he also, by the way, absolutely loathes Custer's wife, is going to be very, very important. So the broader picture, just as we approach the break, the broader picture is they've been sent there because of a looming conflict with the Cheyenne. So these are nomadic, high plains, Native Americans, Indians, whatever terminology you like to use. And we will probably be incredibly inconsistent when we tell them that. Whenever there's any doubt about these things, we just use every possible permutation. Well, I think what it is, is that Nativeicans is obviously the phrase that tends to be used today yeah but that when people
顺便提一下，他非常厌恶卡斯特的妻子，这一点将变得非常非常重要。所以，在我们进入休息时间之前，从更广阔的背景来看，他们被派往那里是因为与夏延人之间即将爆发冲突。所以这些人是游牧的高原美洲原住民、印第安人，或者任何你喜欢的称呼。当我们提到他们时，我们可能会非常不一致。每当对这些称呼有疑问时，我们就会使用所有可能的组合。嗯，我认为是这样的，美洲原住民显然是今天倾向于使用的词汇，是的，但是当人们
are talking about them in the 19th century they tend to use plains indians exactly yeah so we'll be slaloming between those two we will be we absolutely will be in the next episode we will be talking more generally about the context of what were then called the plains indians so we won't get massively into that now but just to give us a sense of the cheyenne the context of what were then called the Plains Indians. So we won't get massively into that now. But just to give us a sense of the Cheyenne, the Cheyenne were originally from the woods of Minnesota. They had moved south and west, so into Montana, Wyoming, the Dakotas, as they would become, as far south as Colorado and Kansas, even Oklahoma.
在19世纪谈论他们时，往往会使用“平原印第安人”，确实如此。所以我们会在两者之间切换，我们绝对会在下一集中更广泛地讨论当时被称为“平原印第安人”的背景，所以我们现在不会深入探讨。但为了让我们对夏延人有个了解，夏延人最初来自明尼苏达州的森林。他们向南和向西迁移，进入了后来的蒙大拿州、怀俄明州、达科他州，甚至远至南部的科罗拉多州、堪萨斯州，甚至是俄克拉荷马州。
Like lots of the so-called Plains Indians, they had taken very quickly to the horse. Horses had become massive to them. And through that, they had got massively quickly to the horse horses have become massive to them and through that they had got massively into the culture of the bison so bison hunting had become a bigger and bigger bigger thing and their world has always been changing enormously in the last 100 150 years as they get into the bison hunting as they get the horses they're affected by disease and all the time their world is changing because of migration. So people coming across their lands to go to the west coast of the United States on the Oregon Trail or following the rivers.
像许多所谓的平原印第安人一样，他们很快就适应了马匹。马对他们来说变得至关重要。通过这种方式，他们迅速融入了野牛文化，因此狩猎野牛变得越来越重要。在过去的一百五十年里，他们的世界发生了巨大的变化，随着他们开始狩猎野牛和拥有马匹，他们受到了疾病的影响，而且由于迁徙，他们的世界一直在改变。人们穿过他们的土地前往美国西海岸，沿着俄勒冈小径或顺着河流前进。
So the railroads are the big thing, aren't they? Yeah, the railroads are huge. So they perceive the railroads as a great threat, understandably, to their way of life. And actually, I mean, just to anticipate what we'll be talking about next time the american bigwigs the army commanders the politicians businessmen they too see the railroads as a way to basically extirpate the plains indians so general sherman 1867 he talks about the railroads he says when they reach the base of the rocky mountains
所以铁路是件大事，不是吗？是的，铁路非常重要。所以他们理所当然地认为铁路对他们的生活方式构成了巨大威胁。事实上，我想预告一下我们下次要谈的内容，美国的权贵们、军队指挥官、政客和商人们，他们也把铁路视为从根本上铲除平原印第安人的一种方式。所以谢尔曼将军在1867年谈到铁路时说，当它们到达落基山脉底部时
when the indian title to roam at will over the country line between them is extinguished then the solution to the most complicated question of indian hostilities will be comparatively easy for this belt of country will naturally fill up with our own people now the cheyenne know this they're not idiots and they basically have the choice do we fight back against this because that would mean massive reprisals from the americans or do we do nothing in which case we're kind of doomed because all our lands will be taken up or do you try and negotiate which is what a very prominent cheyenne leader called black kettle does isn't he he does he does indeed exactly but then there's the opposing kind of more militant side is summed up by the dog soldiers.
当印第安人在两国之间土地上随意游荡的权利被消灭时，解决印第安敌对行动这一最复杂问题的方案将变得相对容易，因为这片地带自然会填满我们自己的人民。夏延人知道这一点，他们并不傻，他们基本上有选择：我们要反击吗？因为那意味着美国人的大规模报复；还是我们什么都不做？如果是那样，我们注定要灭亡，因为我们所有的土地都会被夺走；或者你尝试谈判，这正是那位非常著名的夏延领袖黑壶所做的，不是吗？他确实做了，完全正确。但随后，以“狗兵”为代表的对立的、更激进的一方出现了。
The dog soldiers. So the Cheyenne, like a lot of such peoples, have formed kind of warrior fraternities or societies, mainly for bison hunting. And the dog soldiers are the most militant of these. If you're young, if you're kind of a real alpha male and you want to get war honors and you want to have an exciting time, you want to fight your enemies, you want to hunt lots of buffalo, you want lots of prestige within your group, you might want to join the dog soldiers. And the dog soldiers, they're a warrior people. They are used to fighting and conquering, so war seems completely reasonable to them. But they also have a lot of advantages. They're very mobile.
“狗兵”。所以夏延人，像许多这样的民族一样，组建了某种战士兄弟会或社团，主要是为了狩猎野牛。而“狗兵”是其中最激进的。如果你年轻，如果你是一个真正的阿尔法男性，你想获得战争荣誉，想度过一段激动人心的时光，想与敌人战斗，想猎杀大量的野牛，想在你的群体中获得很高的声望，你可能想加入“狗兵”。“狗兵”是战士民族。他们习惯于战斗和征服，所以战争对他们来说似乎完全合理。但他们也有很多优势。他们非常机动。
They know the terrain. They sort of think, listen, we're not going to take this line down. We could actually see these people off the railroads and whatnot. I mean, it's not a massively, I mean, we know now, Tom, that it's a bad calculation. Well, I suppose they have a sense that, you know, they've been busy fighting other groups of Native Americans, left, right, and center. So they probably assume that the white people are just another people to fight against. Yeah. I think the trend among historians now is to say, you know, obviously,
他们熟悉地形。他们心想，听着，我们不会就这样忍气吞声。我们实际上可以把这些人从铁路等地赶走。我的意思是，这并不是一个……我的意思是，汤姆，我们现在知道这是一个错误的算计。嗯，我想他们有一种感觉，你知道，他们一直忙于与美洲原住民的其他群体作战，左冲右突。所以他们可能认为白人只是另一个可以对抗的民族。是的。我认为历史学家现在的趋势是说，你知道，显然，
I mean, we'll talk about this next time. Obviously in the Native American tribes and peoples, they're never united. That they don't actually think it's us versus, you know, the white settlers. They think of the white settlers as one variable among many. I mean, but obviously someone like Black Kettle is smarter. I mean, he understands what he's up against. Exactly. Yes. But the dogs, they're also being provoked, by the way.
我的意思是，我们下次会谈到这一点。显然，在美洲原住民部落和民族中，他们从来没有统一过。他们实际上并不认为这是“我们”对抗“白人定居者”。他们认为白人定居者只是众多变量中的一个。我的意思是，但显然像黑壶这样的人更聪明。我的意思是，他明白他所面对的是什么。完全正确。是的。但顺便说一句，狗兵们也受到了挑衅。
Of course, massively. So in 1864, for example, during the Civil War, there'd been a horrendous massacre at a place called Sand Creek, where as volunteer cavalry unit had attacked a village and they'd killed 150 people two-thirds of them women and children completely unprovoked a really really horrendous atrocity that frankly if it had happened somewhere else to different people would be well known today but because it happened where it did and because of the romance of the west and because of all this kind of thing, it's just buried and everybody's forgotten that it ever happened.
当然，非常严重。例如，在1864年，内战期间，在一个叫沙溪的地方发生了一场可怕的屠杀，一支志愿骑兵部队袭击了一个村庄，杀死了150人，其中三分之二是妇女和儿童，完全是无缘无故的。这是一场非常非常可怕的暴行，坦率地说，如果它发生在其他地方、针对不同的人，今天会广为人知，但因为它发生在那里，而且因为西部的浪漫色彩以及所有这类事情，它被掩盖了，每个人都忘记了它曾经发生过。
But because of this, the dog soldiers are really kind of up in arms. And by the end of the civil war, by the late 1860s, they're mounting loads and loads of raids. And that's what Custer has been sent to the West to handle. The guy who sent him is general William Sherman, William Tecumseh Sherman.
但正因为如此，狗兵们真的有点武装起来了。到内战结束时，到19世纪60年代末，他们发动了大量的袭击。这就是卡斯特被派往西部去处理的事情。派他去的人是威廉·谢尔曼将军，威廉·特库姆塞·谢尔曼。
So that's a Native American name, isn't it? He's got a Native American second name. I mean, there are so many complexities and ironies in this story. Tecumseh was a Shawnee who had fought with the British in the War of 1812. So obviously a splendid man, Tom. We very much approve of him yeah Sherman has been given his name as a second name because it connotes nobility prowess
所以那是一个美洲原住民的名字，不是吗？他有一个美洲原住民的中间名。我的意思是，这个故事里有太多的复杂性和讽刺意味。特库姆塞是一个肖尼人，曾在1812年战争中与英国人并肩作战。所以显然是个了不起的人，汤姆。我们非常赞赏他。是的，谢尔曼被赋予了他的名字作为中间名，因为它暗示了高贵和英勇。
yeah I mean I hate to use the phrase because it's obviously such a loaded phrase but it's the noble savage isn't it that sort of stereotype
是的，我的意思是，我讨厌使用这个短语，因为它显然是一个带有偏见的短语，但这就是“高贵的野蛮人”，不是吗？那种刻板印象。
that was there in the 18th and 19th century I think it's a bit more than that because I think Tecumseh was I mean he was a power player
那是18世纪和19世纪存在的，我认为这不仅仅是那样，因为我认为特库姆塞是……我的意思是，他是一个权力玩家。
yes he was a really significant figure I mean he wasn't just a kind of doomed romantic. No, I guess not. So anyway, Sherman. Sherman was one of the big stars of the Civil War for the Union camp for the North. He had led this famous march through Georgia, scorched earth policy. His name is Mud in the South, but he's a great war hero for the North. He's a very kind of grizzled man. He's a kind of ruthless commander. Sherman has very complicated views about the Plains Indians. On the one hand, he feels quite sorry for them. He says, I feel pity for the poor devil who wriggles against his, and he hates people who are exploiting the
是的，他是一个非常重要的人物，我的意思是，他不仅仅是一个注定失败的浪漫主义者。不，我想不是。所以无论如何，谢尔曼。谢尔曼是内战中北方联邦阵营的大明星之一。他领导了著名的向佐治亚进军，实行焦土政策。他在南方名声扫地，但他是北方伟大的战争英雄。他是一个非常饱经风霜的人。他是一个冷酷的指挥官。谢尔曼对平原印第安人有非常复杂的看法。一方面，他为他们感到相当难过。他说，我为那个在他面前挣扎的可怜鬼感到怜悯，他讨厌那些剥削
Indians or who are treating them as less than human or any of this kind of stuff. On the other hand, Sherman says explicitly, it's an inevitable conflict of races, one that must occur where a stronger race is gradually displacing a weaker. And Dominic, that's not so dissimilar to Custer's attitude either, is it? It is Custer's attitude, isn't it? Yes. Because Custer also is very much a white supremacist, thinks in terms of race, but does also say repeatedly in his autobiography, My Life on the Plains, which Bentine wittily called My Lies on the Plains. But in that he says, if I were an Indian, I would not want to go on a
印第安人或把他们视为非人或任何这类事情的人。另一方面，谢尔曼明确表示，这是一场不可避免的种族冲突，必然发生在更强大的种族逐渐取代较弱种族的地区。多米尼克，这和卡斯特的态度也没什么不同，不是吗？这确实是卡斯特的态度，不是吗？是的。因为卡斯特也非常白人至上，从种族的角度思考，但他在自传《我在平原上的生活》（本廷幽默地称之为《我在平原上的谎言》）中也反复说，如果我是印第安人，我不想去
reservation. I would fight. He does say that. A lot of the military men say stuff like that. They say, I respect the Indians. And if I was an Indian, I'd be one of them. I'd be fighting too, but I'm not. And we have to win and they have to lose. And that's just the law of nature. That's the way they express it. So Sherman says, right right full crackdown on the cheyenne he sends another war hero winfield scott hancock to command the expedition winfield scott hancock is a veteran of gettysburg as custer is so that's pickett's charge wasn't it he'd seen off pickett's charge yeah the high watermark of the confederacy so in other lights winfield scott hancock is a good guy but i think in this story that would be a very that would be a stretch tom to say the least So in other lights, Winfield Scott Hancock is a good guy.
保留地。我会战斗。他确实这么说了。许多军人都这么说。他们说，我尊重印第安人。如果我是印第安人，我会成为他们中的一员。我也会战斗，但我不是。我们必须赢，他们必须输。这就是自然法则。这就是他们表达的方式。所以谢尔曼说，好吧，对夏延人进行全面镇压。他派了另一位战争英雄温菲尔德·斯科特·汉考克来指挥这次远征。温菲尔德·斯科特·汉考克是葛底斯堡战役的老兵，卡斯特也是，所以那是皮克特冲锋，不是吗？他见证了皮克特冲锋。是的，邦联的最高水位线。所以从其他角度看，温菲尔德·斯科特·汉考克是个好人，但我认为在这个故事中，汤姆，说他是好人会非常牵强，至少可以这么说。
But I think in this story, that would be a very, that would be a stretch, Tom, to say the least. He actually is itching for war. He can't wait to have a crack at the Cheyenne. And when he marches out at the end of March 1867, he takes with him eight companies of the 7th Cavalry. And of course, at the head is their commander, George Armstrong Custer. So should we take a break there? And when we come back, we will see how that all goes and what Custer's role in it is.
但在故事中，汤姆，说他是好人会非常牵强，至少可以这么说。他实际上渴望战争。他迫不及待地想给夏延人一点颜色看看。当他在1867年3月底出发时，他带上了第7骑兵团的八个连。当然，带头的是他们的指挥官乔治·阿姆斯特朗·卡斯特。那么我们在这里休息一下吗？当我们回来时，我们将看看这一切进展如何，以及卡斯特在其中扮演了什么角色。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello welcome back to The Rest Is History and we are following Custer on the war trail. He is marching out to take on the Cheyenne.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》，我们正在跟随卡斯特走上战争之路。他正行军去对付夏延人。
And he is in the Hancock expedition, Dominic. Yes. Which on the 27th of March, 1867, marched out of Fort Riley. And it puts on quite a show, doesn't it? Yeah, it's huge. It's 1,400 men. At that point, I think it's the largest American force, United States force, that has ever been assembled on the Great Plains. And they're, you know, they're jangling kind of cavalry and stuff. I mean, it's a very impressive site. And there are some big names. Yes, some absolute celebrities.
他参加了汉考克远征，多米尼克。是的。1867年3月27日，他们从赖利堡出发。这确实是一场盛大的表演，不是吗？是的，规模很大。有1400人。在那一点上，我认为这是在大平原上集结过的最大的美国军队。他们叮当作响的骑兵等等。我的意思是，这是一个非常令人印象深刻的景象。而且有一些大人物。是的，一些绝对的名人。
So you've got Wild Bill Hickok, who's got a kind of a multicoloured jacket. He's got these tremendous moustaches, which are kind of blowing in the wind. You've got Henry M. Stanley, who will go on to discover Dr. Livingston in Africa and end up with a statue in Wales. And of course, there's Custer, who likewise, I mean, is thoroughly dressed up for the occasion so he's kind of wearing buckskin he's got his revolvers the holster sticking forwards rather than backwards which is very wild bill hickok isn't it that's what it's kind of trend he's set yeah he's got moccasins knee-high moccasins what a thing and he's got his dogs dominic He's got his five favourite hunting dogs. Rover, Lou, Sharp, Fanny and Rattler. So hold on. Fanny. He'd been nicknamed Fanny, hadn't he? What is going on there? But Rover could not be more banal. I'm disappointed with Custer for that. But when he goes back to New York, he can consult his therapist about all this.
所以你有“野牛比尔”希科克，他穿着一件五颜六色的夹克。他有巨大的胡子，在风中飘动。你有亨利·M·斯坦利，他后来在非洲发现了利文斯顿博士，并在威尔士留下了一座雕像。当然，还有卡斯特，他同样，我的意思是，为这个场合精心打扮，所以他穿着鹿皮，他的左轮手枪枪套向前而不是向后，这非常像“野牛比尔”希科克，不是吗？这就是他设定的趋势。是的，他穿着莫卡辛鞋，及膝的莫卡辛鞋，真是个东西。他还有他的狗，多米尼克。他有五只最喜欢的猎犬。罗孚、卢、夏普、范妮和拉特勒。等等。范妮。他被昵称为范妮，不是吗？那里发生了什么？但罗孚再平庸不过了。我对卡斯特感到失望。但当他回到纽约时，他可以就所有这些去咨询他的治疗师。
He can indeed. But for now, he's galloping off. It's all very exciting. So on April 12 12th of April, so they've been gone for about just over two weeks, they meet the leaders of the Cheyenne. And this is a very, very strange encounter. So there's a big burning fire. It's an evening meeting.
他确实可以。但现在，他正飞驰而去。这一切都非常令人兴奋。所以4月12日，他们已经离开两周多一点了，他们见到了夏延人的领袖。这是一次非常非常奇怪的会面。所以有一团熊熊燃烧的火。这是一次晚间会议。
The Cheyenne are there in their absolute finery. So they've got blankets, they're painted, they've got kind of huge arm rings and their scalp locks are adorned with silver discs and all this kind of. They look fantastic. But not the big feathered headdresses. No. Because that is Lakota.
夏延人穿着他们绝对华丽的服装。所以他们有毯子，他们画了彩绘，他们有巨大的臂环，他们的头皮锁上装饰着银盘等等。他们看起来棒极了。但不是那种巨大的羽毛头饰。不。因为那是拉科塔人的。
That is Lakota Sioux thing, exactly. And Hancock handles this in a very peculiar way. He's incredibly aggressive. He says, I've got a lot of soldiers. He says, I've got more soldiers than all of you put together i've heard that you want to fight well brilliant bring it on we can't wait to fight i've come prepared for war if you're for peace you know the conditions if you're for war look out for its consequences and he knows they're very perturbed about the railways and he says to them we're building railroads and we're building roads out of the country you
那是拉科塔苏族的东西，完全正确。汉考克以一种非常奇特的方式处理这件事。他极其咄咄逼人。他说，我有很多士兵。他说，我的士兵比你们所有人加起来还要多。我听说你们想打仗，好极了，来吧，我们迫不及待地想打仗。我已经为战争做好了准备。如果你想要和平，你知道条件。如果你想要战争，小心后果。他知道他们对铁路非常不安，他对他们说，我们正在建设铁路，我们正在建设通往该国的道路，你们
mustn't let your young men stop them the The steam car on the wagon train must run. And there's this guy called Tall Bull who's kind of puffing his pipe and says to him, look, the railroads are very bad for us. They're putting great pressure on the buffalo. When people come, they're shooting at us. They're kind of taking pot shots at buffalo out of the windows of the trains,
绝不能让你们的年轻人阻止它们。马车队上的蒸汽机车必须运行。有个叫高牛的家伙，他一边抽着烟斗一边对他说，看，铁路对我们非常不利。它们给野牛带来了巨大的压力。当人们来的时候，他们向我们开枪。他们从火车窗户里向野牛射击，
taking pot shots at us. It's very poor form from the settlers. And Hancock says, yeah, you are losing your buffalo. Nothing we can do about that. The white men are becoming a great nation. You must keep your young men off the roads. Don't stop the trains and travelers on the roads and you won't be harmed.
向我们射击。定居者的行为非常恶劣。汉考克说，是的，你们正在失去野牛。对此我们无能为力。白人正在成为一个伟大的民族。你们必须让你们的年轻人远离道路。不要阻止火车和路上的旅客，你们就不会受到伤害。
And then he just says, I have spoken and goes away again. And the meeting ends. Now, unbelievably, Hancock, who has conducted this meeting in this fashion after the meeting when people say how do you think it went he says oh terrible i've never been so poorly treated in my life they were incredibly disrespectful to me yeah he's been unbelievably rude and sort of preemptory to them do we know what the cheyenne thought of it well sean clearly very offended by this from from hancock yeah he would be but hancock he's decided that he's going
然后他只是说，我说完了，又走开了。会议结束了。现在，令人难以置信的是，以这种方式进行会议的汉考克，在会议结束后，当人们问他觉得进展如何时，他说，哦，太糟糕了，我这辈子从来没有受到过如此糟糕的对待。他们对我极其不尊重。是的，他一直对他们极其粗鲁和专横。我们知道夏延人是怎么想的吗？嗯，夏延人显然对此感到非常冒犯，来自汉考克。是的，他会这样，但汉考克，他决定他要
to be offended whatever they do i mean they could have been as as friendly. Yeah, he would be. But Hancock, he's decided that he's going to be offended, whatever they do. I mean, they could have been as friendly as anything, and he would claim he was provoked. Because he clearly wants to make a name for himself on the frontier. Yeah, but he doesn't want to march his troops up the hill and then march them back down again. No, exactly. So he says, right, lads, we're
无论他们做什么都要感到被冒犯。我的意思是，他们本可以像什么一样友好。是的，他会这样。但汉考克，他决定无论他们做什么，他都要感到被冒犯。我的意思是，他们本可以非常友好，而他会声称自己受到了挑衅。因为他显然想在边境上为自己扬名。是的，但他不想把他的部队开上山，然后再开下来。不，完全正确。所以他说，好吧，小伙子们，我们
going to march on their villages and make a show of force and intimidate them. He marches on their villages, the encampments, and he gets there and he finds they're completely deserted. The Cheyennes have gone. And this is the big thing, isn't it? That they are incredibly mobile and they know the land. Yeah. And they're not going to stand like a kind of Napoleonic army and draw up in lines. No, they've behaved, Tom, I think not unreasonably. They've said, this bloke's clearly on the warpath. Let's get out of here.
要向他们的村庄进军，展示武力并恐吓他们。他向他们的村庄、营地进军，他到达那里时发现它们完全空无一人。夏延人已经走了。这就是重点，不是吗？他们极其机动，而且他们了解这片土地。是的。他们不会像拿破仑军队那样站着排成队。不，汤姆，我认为他们的行为并非不合理。他们说，这家伙显然在战争之路上。我们走吧。
And they've gone. Hancock arrives at the village and he says, this is unbelievable. Poor form. Absolutely disgraceful behavior that they should have left. Cheating. And he says to Custer, pursue them immediately. So Custer sets off with the 7th Cavalry over the hills and gullies and bonhorns.
他们走了。汉考克到达村庄，他说，这太不可思议了。行为恶劣。他们离开的行为绝对可耻。作弊。他对卡斯特说，立即追击他们。所以卡斯特带着第7骑兵团翻山越岭，穿过沟壑和山谷。
And actually, we may have slightly underplayed the Cheyennes. The Cheyennes are capable of being very brutal. Because Custer starts to get to these sort of lookout posts. He gets to one with the very unimaginative name of Lookout Station. And he finds that it's been ravaged and the three blokes who were sort of in charge of it, they've been burned alive, it seems
事实上，我们可能稍微低估了夏延人。夏延人有能力变得非常残忍。因为卡斯特开始到达这些所谓的了望哨。他到达了一个名字非常缺乏想象力的了望站。他发现它已经被蹂躏了，负责那里的三个人，他们似乎被活活烧死了，
like, and their intestines have been ripped out and kind of thrown all over the ground. The Cheyennes are great ones for chopping off the testicles,'t they leaving them on rocks yeah there's a lot of this good conduct so custer sends a message to hancock and he says as you said as you predicted the shayan have butchered our men very bad behavior and hancock says right i'll burn the village so he burns all the villages now there's actually no evidence that the people from the village had carried this out. He doesn't care. He's just itching to do the reprisals.
他们的肠子被掏出来，扔得满地都是。夏延人很喜欢割掉睾丸，不是吗？把它们留在石头上。是的，这种行为很多。所以卡斯特给汉考克发了一条信息，他说，正如你所说，正如你预料的那样，夏延人屠杀了我们的人，行为非常恶劣。汉考克说，好吧，我要烧掉这个村庄。所以他烧毁了所有的村庄。现在实际上没有证据表明村里的人实施了这些行为。他不在乎。他只是渴望进行报复。
And of course, this provokes then a general Cheyenne kind of uprising. So then there's attacks on stagecoaches and there's attacks on settlers and all this kind of on bizarrely Custer has now lost focus completely because he's getting a lot of letters from Libby who's back in one of these forts and they've clearly had a gigantic falling out but we don't really know what about all we know is that Custer is sending her all these letters where he's saying I know I promised you never to look at other girls. I wish I'd never saw those two again and all this kind of thing. So clearly he's been carrying on in some obscure way with other women. It would be fair to say he has a high sex drive. Yeah. He's let himself down, Tom. Yes.
当然，这随后引发了夏延人的全面起义。于是出现了对驿站马车的袭击，对定居者的袭击，所有这些。奇怪的是，卡斯特现在完全失去了焦点，因为他收到了很多来自利比的信，她回到了其中一个堡垒，他们显然发生了一场巨大的争吵，但我们真的不知道是为了什么。我们只知道卡斯特给她发了所有这些信，他在信中说，我知道我答应过你永远不看其他女孩。我真希望我再也没见过那两个人，所有这类事情。所以显然他以某种隐晦的方式与其他女性有染。公平地说，他的性欲很强。是的。他让自己失望了，汤姆。是的。
I don't know whether it's just flirtation or whether it's something more. I mean, this question of whether it is flirtation or something more is something that will come up towards the end of this episode. Yeah. So, listeners, bear that in mind. Well, also, he's trying to cheer himself up by reading The Anatomy of Melancholy by Robert Burton. Yeah, that wouldn't cheer me up. That wouldn't cheer you up at all.
我不知道这只是调情还是更严重的事情。我的意思是，这是否只是调情或更严重的问题，是本集结尾会出现的问题。是的。所以，听众们，请记住这一点。嗯，另外，他正试图通过阅读罗伯特·伯顿的《忧郁的解剖》来让自己振作起来。是的，那不会让我振作起来。那根本不会让你振作起来。
That's a mad book to have taken on a frontier expedition. And so he gets very scratchy, doesn't he? And everyone's basically deserting. And so he kind of lashes dessert as he mows some of them down yeah uh refused to give medical treatment to the survivors he's losing it actually i think yeah he's heading towards colonel kurt's territory isn't he yeah people get drunk they're made to wear barrels aren't they they stick the head and the feet and they have to kind of walk around with this looking like a barrel human barrel for kind of a week or something
那是一本带去边境远征的疯狂的书。所以他变得非常暴躁，不是吗？每个人基本上都在逃跑。所以他有点猛烈抨击逃兵，他杀了一些人。是的，拒绝给幸存者提供医疗救助。他实际上正在失去理智，我想。他正朝着库尔茨上校的领地走去，不是吗？是的，人们喝醉了，他们被迫穿上木桶，不是吗？他们把头和脚伸出来，他们不得不带着这个走来走去，看起来像一个木桶，人类木桶，持续一周左右。
it's a very strange punishment, isn't it? Yeah. I think life on the frontier, the way you describe it, I mean, that business with Mrs. Nash, people having to dress as barrels. Ant fights. That's not what I expected. I thought it would be all shootouts and gambling. But against that, I do think that Custer is capable of finding excitement in the most
这是一种非常奇怪的惩罚，不是吗？是的。我认为边境上的生活，你描述的方式，我的意思是，纳什夫人那件事，人们不得不打扮成木桶。蚂蚁大战。这不是我所期望的。我以为会全是枪战和赌博。但与之相对的是，我确实认为卡斯特有能力在最
extraordinary places. And he's obviously very kind of depressed, down on his luck, putting people in barrels, all this kind of thing. And then he gets direct orders, doesn't he, to go out and... Roam the plains looking for the Cheyenne. Roam the plains. And he doesn't. And so Sherman sends a guy called Kidder. Yeah.
非凡的地方找到兴奋。他显然非常沮丧，运气不好，把人关进木桶，所有这类事情。然后他接到了直接命令，不是吗？去……在平原上游荡寻找夏延人。在平原上游荡。但他没有。所以谢尔曼派了一个叫基德的人。是的。
Lieutenant Kidder. This is a bad business. Basically telling him, you know, do what you're told. Yeah. Custerder. This is a bad business. Basically tell him, you know, do what you're told. Yeah. Custer, as usual, is not obeying orders.
基德中尉。这是一件坏事。基本上告诉他，你知道，按吩咐去做。是的。卡斯特，像往常一样，没有服从命令。
And Kidder, he's got a Lakota scout with him. He's got 10 men to look after him. Going towards where Custer is and they get ambushed by the Cheyenne. They do.
基德，他带了一个拉科塔侦察兵。他有10个人照顾他。前往卡斯特所在的地方，他们遭到了夏延人的伏击。他们确实遭到了伏击。
And horribly, horribly murdered. So Custer writes, the sinews of the arms and legs have been cut away the nose of every man hacked off and the features otherwise defaced we could not even distinguish the officer from his men lots of testicle hacking all that kind of thing yeah but custer in my life on the plains he phrases this in the most extraordinary way he imagines them being chased cornered and
而且被极其可怕地谋杀了。所以卡斯特写道，手臂和腿的筋被切断了，每个人的鼻子都被砍掉了，面部特征也被毁坏了，我们甚至无法区分军官和他的士兵。有很多割睾丸之类的事情。是的，但卡斯特在《我在平原上的生活》中以最非凡的方式表达了这一点。他想象他们被追赶、逼入绝境和
murdered and he says how painfully, almost despairingly exciting must have been this ride for life. And that I think does really sum up something distinctive about Custer. Yeah. That he can imagine that as being exciting, as being fun. Also, what is typical is that Custer at no point expresses any guilt about the fact that these poor people have been killed because of him. Yeah. He should be very guilty about this because they've been sent out to bring him orders and if he'd actually obeyed his earlier orders, this might not have happened. So at the time, I mean, he says it's exciting in his memoirs,
谋杀，他说，这次求生之旅是多么痛苦，几乎令人绝望地令人兴奋。我认为这确实总结了卡斯特的一些独特之处。是的。他可以想象那令人兴奋，很有趣。同样，典型的是，卡斯特在任何时候都没有表达任何内疚，因为这些人因为他而被杀。是的。他应该对此感到非常内疚，因为他们被派出来给他传达命令，如果他真的服从了他之前的命令，这可能就不会发生了。所以当时，我的意思是，他在回忆录中说这很令人兴奋，
but at the time, he's deep in his kind of pit of despair, isn't he, about his wife? Because he's also got a letter now from somebody who says, you want to look after your wife a little closer. Because apparently she's been carrying on with the man called Lieutenant Weir, who is described as a handsome and charming young alcoholic. That's probably the best you can do in a seventh-calorie fort. I guess so.
但在当时，他正深陷于关于他妻子的绝望深渊中，不是吗？因为他现在也收到了一封来自某人的信，说，你想多照顾一下你的妻子。因为显然她一直和一个叫威尔中尉的人有染，他被描述为一个英俊迷人的年轻酒鬼。这可能是你在第七骑兵团堡垒里能做到的最好的了。我想是这样。
So Custer is desperate to be reunited with her, and he just completely ignores his orders, even after the Kidder massacre. Again, of course. Shoots off across the plains, driving his men very hard. Lots of them are kind of deserting. They're dropping dead around him. They're exhausted. Some of them go missing.
所以卡斯特渴望与她团聚，即使在基德大屠杀之后，他也完全无视了他的命令。当然，再次无视。他在平原上飞驰，非常严厉地驱使他的手下。他们中的许多人都在逃跑。他们在他身边倒下。他们精疲力竭。他们中的一些人失踪了。
He won't send out a search party for them. And then actually one bloke ends up being killed by the Cheyenne. They basically leave him behind. And finally, when Custer gets to one of these forts, he is arrested. He's just gone completely bonkers. He's arrested and he ends up being charged with a gross dereliction of duty, not unreasonably. As well he might. Yeah. And in October 1867, he is found guilty and he is actually suspended for a year. And at that point, you could say he's really let himself down tom do you want to know how he sums this episode up in
他不会派搜救队去找他们。然后实际上有一个家伙最终被夏延人杀死了。他们基本上把他留在了后面。最后，当卡斯特到达其中一个堡垒时，他被逮捕了。他完全疯了。他被逮捕，并最终被指控严重失职，这并非不合理。他理应如此。是的。1867年10月，他被判有罪，并被停职一年。在那一点上，你可以说他真的让自己失望了，汤姆。你想知道他是怎么总结这一集的吗？
my life on the plains i'd love to uh he doesn't mention it he says to enter into a review of the proceedings which followed would be to introduce into these pages matters of too personal character to interest the general reader that's great i should bear that in mind for when I'm disgraced in later life. Making your statement. Exactly. At your Cotswolds gate. Thanks. These are matters that are too personal to be of interest to the general public. So actually he is then rescued by politics.
在《我在平原上的生活》中，我很想知道。嗯，他没有提到它。他说，进入对随后的诉讼程序的审查，将是在这些页面中引入过于个人性质的事项，以引起普通读者的兴趣。那太棒了。我以后丢脸的时候应该记住这一点。发表你的声明。完全正确。在你科茨沃尔德的门口。谢谢。这些事项过于个人化，不引起公众兴趣。所以实际上他随后被政治拯救了。
Weirdly, he's so bad at politics, but politics rescues him because all while this has been happening, all the while Reconstruction, the great controversy about Reconstruction, has been going on on the East Coast and in the South. And his old patron, General Sheridan, who's been the military governor basically of Louisiana and Texas, and is, as it were, on the side of the angels. So he wants to demolish the apparatus of white supremacy. He wants to get rid of the old Confederates.
奇怪的是，他在政治上很糟糕，但政治拯救了他，因为这一切发生的同时，重建，关于重建的巨大争议，一直在东海岸和南方进行。他的老赞助人谢里丹将军，基本上是路易斯安那州和德克萨斯州的军事总督，而且可以说，站在天使一边。所以他想拆除白人至上的机构。他想摆脱旧的邦联分子。
He wants, you know, black people to have the vote. He's very controversial. It sets off a huge political firestorm. And eventually Ulysses S. Grant, who's the Supreme Commander of the Army, to sort of shut up the South, he decides he's going to swap Sheridan and Hancock. So Hancock will go to the South and Sheridan, to get him out of the equation, he'll go over to the West. And Sheridan wants Custer back. He thinks Custer is tremendous at this stage.
他希望，你知道，黑人拥有投票权。他非常有争议。这引发了一场巨大的政治风暴。最终，作为军队最高指挥官的尤利西斯·S·格兰特，为了让南方闭嘴，他决定交换谢里丹和汉考克。所以汉考克将去南方，而谢里丹，为了让他退出这个等式，他将去西部。谢里丹想要卡斯特回来。他认为卡斯特在这个阶段非常了不起。
Custer has been a good cavalry commander for him in the Civil War. He thinks, you know, Custer has blotted his copybook, but I really appreciate him. He's gallant, all of this kind of thing. But this whole kind of dashing around disobeying orders, I mean, in a sense, that's part of the point of Custer. Yes, I suppose so. You can rely on him to do something dashing, even if a little bit mad. Exactly.
卡斯特在内战中曾是他的一名优秀的骑兵指挥官。他认为，你知道，卡斯特弄脏了他的记录，但我真的很欣赏他。他很勇敢，所有这类事情。但这种到处乱跑、不服从命令的行为，我的意思是，在某种意义上，这就是卡斯特的意义所在。是的，我想是这样。你可以指望他做一些冲动的事情，即使有点疯狂。完全正确。
The amazing thing, actually, is that Custer, even at this stage, is still behaving in an incredibly self-destructive manner in politics. So he really does need now Ulysses S. Grant to look kindly upon him because Ulysses S. Grant is the head of the army. Custer has botted his copybook.
事实上，令人惊奇的是，卡斯特即使在这个阶段，在政治上仍然表现出极其自我毁灭的行为。所以他现在确实需要尤利西斯·S·格兰特对他有好感，因为尤利西斯·S·格兰特是军队的首脑。卡斯特弄脏了他的记录。
He needs to get back into Grant's good books. The way he decides to do this is by campaigning against Grant in the presidential election and endorsing his opponent. I mean, again, it is kind of a suicidal charge in politics as in war. Yeah.
他需要回到格兰特的好感中。他决定这样做的方式是在总统选举中竞选反对格兰特，并支持他的对手。我的意思是，这再次是一种政治上的自杀式冲锋，就像在战争中一样。是的。
He makes a special trip to New York to endorse Grant's opponent in the presidential election, a guy called Horatio Seymour. Just bonkers from Custer, actually. Anyway, they overlook that. They're very tolerant of Custer, actually, his superiors. I mean, I don't think they do love him. I don't know if they do find him lovable, but I think they're prepared to cut him a lot of slack because of his achievements in the Civil War.
他专门去纽约支持格兰特在总统选举中的对手，一个叫霍拉肖·西摩的人。卡斯特的行为简直疯了。无论如何，他们忽略了这一点。他们实际上对卡斯特非常宽容，他的上级。我的意思是，我不认为他们爱他。我不知道他们是否觉得他可爱，但我认为他们准备因为他在内战中的成就而对他网开一面。
So General Sheridan says, right, I want you back on the Western frontier. You've had a year's suspension. Please come back. And the reason for this is that they'd actually signed a deal with the majority of the Cheyenne. So this is the Black K actually signed a deal with the majority of the Cheyenne. So this is the black kettle wing. Yes. Yeah. Basically, the Cheyenne would agree to go on this massive reservation, four million
所以谢里丹将军说，好吧，我想要你回到西部边境。你已经被停职一年了。请回来。原因是他们实际上与大多数夏延人签署了一项协议。所以这是黑壶……实际上与大多数夏延人签署了一项协议。所以这是黑壶派系。是的。是的。基本上，夏延人同意去这个巨大的保留地，四百万
acres. They'd be given schoolhouses. They'd have to wear like Western style clothes, as in European style clothes. Become farmers. Exactly. And this treaty, which is signed at Medicine Lodge Creek, it really, I mean, historians now say this is basically the end of the Cheyenne as an independent nomadic hunting people. But the dog soldiers don't like this at all. They sort of rebel against it. They go on
英亩。他们会得到校舍。他们必须穿像西方风格的衣服，也就是欧洲风格的衣服。成为农民。完全正确。这项在医学小屋溪签署的条约，它真的，我的意思是，历史学家现在说这基本上是夏延人作为一个独立的游牧狩猎民族的终结。但狗兵们一点也不喜欢这样。他们反抗它。他们继续
great rampages across Oklahoma, Kansas, Colorado, attacking settlements. They rape women. They butcher men, all of this kind of thing. They would say, these are not atrocities, these are perfectly reasonable acts of war. Of course, we might take a different view. Well, again, it's this, you know, what's a victory, what's a massacre? Exactly, it's that question. So Sherman and Sheridan say, right, okay, gloves off, get Custer. Custer's really good at these charges and stuff.
在俄克拉荷马州、堪萨斯州、科罗拉多州进行大规模的横冲直撞，袭击定居点。他们强奸妇女。他们屠杀男人，所有这类事情。他们会说，这些不是暴行，这些是完全合理的战争行为。当然，我们可能会有不同的看法。嗯，再次，这是这个，你知道，什么是胜利，什么是屠杀？完全正确，就是那个问题。所以谢尔曼和谢里丹说，好吧，没问题，脱掉手套，找卡斯特。卡斯特非常擅长这些冲锋之类的东西。
Let us sort these guys out once and for all. And what we'll do unusually is we'll campaign over the winter. They won't expect that. They just hunker down normally in the winter. It's not really war season for them. And that's the key thing, isn't it? That if they're hunkered down, then they can be cornered. Exactly.
让我们一劳永逸地解决这些家伙。我们要做的是不寻常的，我们将在冬天进行竞选。他们不会预料到这一点。他们通常在冬天蜷缩起来。这对他们来说真的不是战争季节。这就是关键，不是吗？如果他们蜷缩起来，那么他们就可以被逼入绝境。完全正确。
And Sherman and Sheridan, I mean, there are historians who say, these are guys who won the Civil War against the Confederacy by basically steamrolling. Yeah, steamrolling it. Total industrial warfare. Scorched earth. You know, no holds barred. Get it done. And they are now exporting that style of warfare, that violence to the frontier against the
谢尔曼和谢里丹，我的意思是，有历史学家说，这些人是通过基本上碾压赢得了内战，对抗邦联。是的，碾压它。全面的工业战争。焦土。你知道，毫无保留。把它做完。他们现在正在将那种战争风格、那种暴力出口到边境，对抗
Plains Indians who have no idea what's coming. Custer, of course, he dresses up for the occasion. He gets himself a new buckskin costume so he again he's cutting a bit of a dash takes his dogs all of that stuff
平原印第安人，他们根本不知道会发生什么。卡斯特，当然，他为这个场合打扮。他给自己弄了一套新的鹿皮服装，所以他再次显得很时髦，带上他的狗，所有这些东西。
and he leads out his men through Oklahoma through the snows and through the blizzards and finally he finds a big Cheyenne village on the banks
他带领他的手下穿过俄克拉荷马州，穿过雪地和暴风雪，最后他在河岸上发现了一个巨大的夏延村庄
of the river Washita so he's tracking a war band isn't he he is and it leads it to this village. The problem is, it's the village where Black Kettle is based. The peace advocate. The peace
沃希托河，所以他正在追踪一个战争团伙，不是吗？他是，它导致了这个村庄。问题是，这是黑壶所在的村庄。和平倡导者。和平
advocate. Yeah. They could not be less hostile. It's a terrible irony, Tom. Anyway, Custer has got to this village. It's night. He says to his men, he's got about 800 of them or so, and he says to them, them right we'll divide up into four parties no fires total silence we'll wait till dawn the signal will be they have a sort of irish jig marching song called gary owen and he says we'll play this song the band will play that's when we attack and there's a really telling exchange, one of his officers says to him, and this brilliantly anticipates the disaster at Little Bighorn, because one officer says to him, what if we find more Indians than we're expecting? Custer says, you know, there's no
倡导者。是的。他们不可能不那么敌对。这是一个可怕的讽刺，汤姆。无论如何，卡斯特已经到达了这个村庄。是晚上了。他对他的手下说，他有大约800人左右，他对他们说，好吧，我们分成四组，没有火，完全安静，我们等到黎明。信号将是，他们有一种爱尔兰吉格舞曲，叫“加里·欧文”，他说我们会演奏这首歌，乐队会演奏，那就是我们进攻的时候。有一个非常能说明问题的交流，他的一名军官对他说，这出色地预示了小大角战役的灾难，因为一名军官对他说，如果我们发现的印第安人比我们预期的多怎么办？卡斯特说，你知道，没有
such thing as too many. The problem will be if we find too few. We want loads so we can deal with them, kill them all, kill them all. There are not Indians enough in the country to whip the 7th Cavalry. Very hubristic statement, of course. So they wait. And they know there are women and children in the village, of course, because they can hear children crying. They can hear babies crying and things. And they can hear dogs, can't they?
所谓太多。问题是我们发现的太少。我们想要很多，这样我们就可以对付他们，杀死他们，杀死他们。这个国家没有足够的印第安人来鞭打第7骑兵团。当然，非常傲慢的声明。所以他们等待。他们知道村里有妇女和儿童，当然，因为他们能听到孩子们的哭声。他们能听到婴儿的哭声等等。他们能听到狗叫，不是吗？
They can. And then one of Custer's dogs barks and he orders it strangled. And only one of the dogs is spared, Blucher, his favourite staghound, who then in the fighting gets killed because he attacks the wrong people. Tom Custer and his brother, Tom, strangle the dogs with lassoos. I mean, that is brutal. Yeah. So dawn comes, the smoke begins to rise from the indian lodges below
他们能。然后卡斯特的一只狗叫了，他下令把它勒死。只有一只狗幸免于难，布吕歇尔，他最喜欢的猎犬，后来在战斗中被杀，因为它攻击了错误的人。汤姆·卡斯特和他的兄弟汤姆用套索勒死了狗。我的意思是，那太残忍了。是的。所以黎明来了，烟雾开始从下面的印第安小屋升起
cheyenne lodges and custer says right band strike up you know dawn is breaking and they charge and all the accounts say custer loves it they're charging down blazing away with their revolvers the cheyenne are taken totally and utterly by surprise because the sentry had been asleep yes which is very unshamed behavior well they're not expecting it either in the winter you know it's cold they don't think the americans will strike they ride in it's very wild west sort of hollywood scene but for the fact that actually when you get close up, you realize just how horrendous this all is. So Custer's men have Osage guides, so arrival planes people. Who are the people who make all the money,
夏延小屋，卡斯特说，好吧，乐队开始演奏，你知道，黎明正在破晓，他们冲锋了。所有的记录都说卡斯特喜欢它，他们冲锋下去，用左轮手枪猛烈射击。夏延人被完全彻底地打了个措手不及，因为哨兵睡着了，是的，这非常不符合夏延人的行为。嗯，他们也没想到，在冬天，你知道，天气很冷，他们不认为美国人会进攻。他们骑马冲进去，这非常像好莱坞式的西部片场景，但事实上，当你近距离观察时，你会意识到这一切是多么可怕。所以卡斯特的手下有奥塞奇向导，所以是敌对的平原民族。他们是那些赚了所有钱的人，
don't they? Killers of the Flamoon. Yeah. They behave pretty, how would I put it? Unsentimentally, I think is one way of putting it, Tom. Yeah. So they are ripping Cheyenne apart, committing all of these kind of atrocities, cutting off their people's heads,
不是吗？杀手。是的。他们的行为相当，我该怎么说呢？不带感情色彩，我想这是一种表达方式，汤姆。是的。所以他们正在撕裂夏延人，犯下所有这些暴行，砍掉他们人的头，
beating their brains out, all of this kind of thing. Custer's own men undoubtedly committed what we would consider the most appalling atrocities. They shoot a pregnant woman, rip her stomach open, they take scalps, they fire deliberately on fleeing women and children. Now, Custer is told this, and there's no doubt about it, Custer tells them to stop it. So Custer will discuss, I suppose, how much criticism, how much condemnation he deserves for this, because he could reasonably say he's just following, he's doing exactly what he's been told to do. But he does try to stop his men from shooting women and children. On the other hand, he says, round up all the men and kill them all.
打碎他们的头骨，所有这类事情。卡斯特自己的人无疑犯下了我们认为最令人震惊的暴行。他们射杀了一名孕妇，剖开她的肚子，他们剥下头皮，他们故意向逃跑的妇女和儿童开火。现在，卡斯特被告知了这一点，毫无疑问，卡斯特告诉他们停止。所以卡斯特会讨论，我想，他应该受到多少批评，多少谴责，因为他可以合理地说他只是在跟随，他正在做他被告知要做的完全相同的事情。但他确实试图阻止他的手下射杀妇女和儿童。另一方面，他说，把所有男人围起来，全部杀掉。
And Dominic, round up all the ponies. Yes. So he kills all the ponies. They do. One of the troopers says, it was pathetic to hear the dismal trumpeting. I can find no other word to express my meaning of the dying creatures as the breath of life rushed through severed windpipes. 875 ponies they killed.
多米尼克，把所有小马围起来。是的。所以他杀死了所有的小马。他们确实这样做了。其中一名骑兵说，听到凄惨的号角声是可悲的。我找不到其他词来表达我的意思，当生命的气息通过被切断的气管冲出时，那些垂死的生物。他们杀死了875匹小马。
And then they set the whole village on fire and they burn it. And there are loads of controversial things that happen. They realize actually this is a smaller village and there's a bigger one over the hill. And warriors are arriving from the bigger one. So they round up the women and children. They use them as hostages. And by using them as kind of human shields almost, they kind of feint to march towards the big village.
然后他们放火烧毁了整个村庄。发生了许多有争议的事情。他们意识到实际上这是一个较小的村庄，山上还有一个更大的。战士们正从更大的那个赶来。所以他们围捕了妇女和儿童。他们把他们当作人质。通过把他们当作某种人盾，他们假装向大村庄进军。
The warriors will retreat to defend their village. Then Custer kind of turns and they march away. And this is Custer's innovation, isn't it? The discovery that if you round up women, then the men won't attack. And this again is something that will perhaps explain what he's trying to do at Little Bighorn. Exactly. Meanwhile, one of his men has gone missing, a guy called Elliot.
战士们将撤退以保卫他们的村庄。然后卡斯特转过身，他们就离开了。这就是卡斯特的创新，不是吗？发现如果你把妇女围起来，男人们就不会进攻。这再次解释了他试图在小大角战役中做什么。确实。与此同时，他的一名手下失踪了，一个叫埃利奥特的人。
He's a major, isn't he? Yeah. He's seen careering off yelling, here goes for a brevet or a coffin. Well, he gets one of those. He gets a coffin. He gets a coffin. Elliot goes missing and Custer doesn't search for him,
他是个少校，对吧？是的。有人看到他大喊大叫地冲出去，说“要么获得晋升，要么进棺材”。好吧，他确实得到了其中之一。他得到了一口棺材。他得到了一口棺材。埃利奥特失踪了，卡斯特没有去寻找他，
which is regarded by some people bentine in particular as extremely bad form so they actually find elliot and 17 other men having been butchered by cheyenne warriors they find them yeah testicles on the rocks again and all that yeah exactly in total custer, I mean, he claimed himself 103 people. Some claim actually fewer, but the Cheyenne kind of peace advocate, so there's horrible irony there. Black kettle. And even at the time, in the East Coast newspapers, this is controversial.
这被一些人，特别是本廷，视为极其糟糕的行为。所以他们实际上发现了埃利奥特和其他17名被夏延战士屠杀的人。他们发现了他们，是的，睾丸又被割下来放在石头上等等。是的，完全正确。总共卡斯特，我的意思是，他自己声称杀死了103人。有些人声称实际上更少，但夏延人是和平倡导者，所以这里有一种可怕的讽刺。黑壶。即使在当时，在东海岸的报纸上，这也是有争议的。
When the news of the Washita River battle or massacre breaks some people say oh this is too much you know women and children all of this i mean it's interesting that isn't it because some anyone who's seen the film little big man yeah this is stage knit yes and i think that was made around the time of the me lie massacre yeah 1970. Yeah, 1970, 71, I think it was, something like that. And the parallel was very, very overt. But that's not entirely anachronistic. There is kind of liberal opinion on the East Coast that does regard this as a war crime. Yes. I think actually most historians, most of Custer's biographers now say, by the standards
当沃希托河战役或大屠杀的消息传出时，有些人说哦，这太过分了，你知道妇女和儿童等等。我的意思是，这很有趣，不是吗？因为任何看过电影《小巨人》的人，是的，这是舞台化的，是的。我想那是在美莱大屠杀前后制作的，是的，1970年。是的，我想是1970年或71年左右，类似那样。这种平行是非常明显的。但这并不完全是时代错误。东海岸确实有一种自由派舆论认为这是一种战争罪。是的。我想实际上大多数历史学家，大多数卡斯特的传记作者现在都说，按照边疆的标准，
of the frontier, Custer is not doing anything especially unusual. Well, Sheridan, the Battle of the Rashita River is the most complete and successful of all our private battles and was fought in such unfavorable weather and circumstances as to reflect the highest credit on yourself and regiment. Yeah. That's him writing to Custer. T.J. Stiles says the criticism of Custer is not that it's a bad battle, but it's a bad war and that he is a
卡斯特并没有做什么特别不寻常的事情。好吧，谢里登说，沃希托河战役是我们所有私人战役中最完整、最成功的一次，而且是在如此不利的天气和环境下进行的，这为你本人和你的团赢得了最高的荣誉。是的。那是他写给卡斯特的信。T.J.斯泰尔斯说，对卡斯特的批评不是因为这是一场糟糕的战斗，而是因为这是一场糟糕的战争，而他是那场战争的象征。
symbol of that war. The very existence of the United States was predicated on the dispossession of the indigenous. If Custer was wrong, ultimately it was only because the nation was wrong, says Stiles. I mean, I think Custer has become a kind of shorthand, hasn't he, for what's perceived as the unfairness, the imbalance of these conflicts. I mean, do you have an easy answer, Tom? I don't think there is an easy answer to these kinds of issues. I mean, I think reading it as an outsider, you kind of recoil from the horrendous violence
美国的存在本身就是建立在剥夺原住民的基础上的。斯泰尔斯说，如果卡斯特错了，那最终也只是因为这个国家错了。我的意思是，我认为卡斯特已经成为一种简写，不是吗？代表了人们所认为的这些冲突中的不公平和不平衡。我的意思是，你有一个简单的答案吗，汤姆？我不认为这些问题有什么简单的答案。我的意思是，我认为作为一个局外人阅读这段历史，你会对针对毫无防备的村民所施加的恐怖暴力感到退缩，
dealt out towards unsuspecting villagers. But of course, lots of Americans listening to this might say, you know it was a war they did what they had to do what do you think stephen ambrose wrote a paired biography of custer and crazy horse and he writes about the washita and says it's you know terrible slaughter but at the same time you know the integrity of the united States required the annexation of it, what were prospectors to do, all this kind of thing. And that would be the perspective, I guess, that was traditional throughout the 19th into the 20th century. Obviously, it's changed very radically, I think.
但当然，许多听这个节目的美国人可能会说，你知道这是一场战争，他们做了他们必须做的事。你认为斯蒂芬·安布罗斯写了一本关于卡斯特和疯马的对偶传记，他写到沃希托时说，这你知道是可怕的屠杀，但同时，你知道美国的完整性需要吞并它，探矿者能做什么，所有这些事情。我想这就是从19世纪一直延续到20世纪的传统观点。显然，我认为它已经发生了非常彻底的改变。
Really, since Bury My Heart at Wounded Knee. So it's the early seventies, I mean, late sixties, early seventies. And I think it's very difficult to side with a cavalry troop backed up by all the mechanized might of a great industrial nation descending on women and children. Yeah, I agree with you, Tom. There's nothing heroic about it. Exactly. It's very hard to tell that story. While understanding that Custer is a man of his time, that all of those men are men of their time, while understanding the political pressures and the expectations and the cultural baggage they carried with them, I think if you're making a film of it, let's say, it would be impossible to make a film in which they are the heroes and in which this is a stirring, swashbuckling scene.
真的，自从《在伤膝河埋葬我的心》出版以来。所以那是七十年代初，我的意思是，六十年代末，七十年代初。我认为很难站在一支由一个伟大工业国家的机械化力量支持的骑兵部队一边，去攻击妇女和儿童。是的，我同意你的看法，汤姆。这没什么英雄气概。确实。很难讲述那个故事。在理解卡斯特是他那个时代的人，所有那些人都是他们那个时代的人，在理解他们所承受的政治压力、期望和文化包袱的同时，我认为如果你要拍一部关于它的电影，不可能拍出一部他们是英雄，而这是一场激动人心、充满冒险色彩的场景的电影。
It's a horrendous scene. And there's one further consideration which adds to that, which is the fate of the women. Yeah. So you said Custer stops the women from being killed. He rounds them up.
这是一个可怕的场景。还有一个进一步的考虑增加了这一点，那就是妇女的命运。是的。所以你说卡斯特阻止了妇女被杀。他把她们围了起来。
The women clearly expect that they're going to be horribly tortured because I guess that's what they might do in the other way round. Yes. By the way, we shouldn't idealise,
妇女们显然预料到她们会受到可怕的折磨，因为我想如果反过来，她们可能会那样做。是的。顺便说一句，我们不应该理想化，
I mean, the Cheyenne perpetrate what we would consider horrendous violence against their American captives. I wouldn't really want to be captured by either of them, I have to say. No, agreed. But anyway, sorry, Tom, I interrupted you. So women are rounded up. One of them is Black Kettle's niece, who is a 17-year-old girl, is described as having
我的意思是，夏延人对他们的美国俘虏实施了我们认为可怕的暴力。我必须说，我真的不想被他们中的任何一方俘虏。不，同意。但无论如何，抱歉，汤姆，我打断你了。所以妇女被围了起来。其中一个是黑壶的侄女，一个17岁的女孩，被描述为拥有
beautiful, luxuriant hair. She's very feisty. She had been previously married and shot her inadequate husband through the knee. And Custer loves her, doesn't he? I mean, he's very, very keen on her. Yeah, Mona Sita. And the question of, you know, how far does that go? But there's a kind of rumours of reports of stories, one of them coming from Bentin, but one of them coming from one of Custer's scouts, who'd have no real reason to lie. That basically these women are being pimped out
美丽、浓密的头发。她非常活泼。她之前结过婚，并射伤了她无能丈夫的膝盖。卡斯特爱她，不是吗？我的意思是，他非常非常喜欢她。是的，莫娜·西塔。关于，你知道，这发展到什么程度的问题？但有一些传闻、报告和故事，其中一个来自本廷，但另一个来自卡斯特的一名侦察兵，他没有真正的理由撒谎。基本上这些妇女被翻译官皮条客化了，
by the translator who's called Romero, but is nicknamed Romeo. There are enough different accounts of this. So there are accounts from the Cheyenne that say that after the battle, or the massacre, depending on how you describe it. It's a massacre, isn't it? I mean, it is a massacre. It is a massacre.
那个翻译官叫罗梅罗，但绰号叫罗密欧。关于这一点有足够多不同的说法。所以有来自夏延人的说法，说在战斗或大屠杀之后，取决于你怎么描述它。这是一场大屠杀，不是吗？我的意思是，这是一场大屠杀。这是一场大屠杀。
Totally a massacre. I mean, it's got women and children. It's got a village where they're unsuspecting. If the Vikings had done this, Tom, you know, in Wessex, we would describe it as a massacre. I mean, it's got women and children. It's got a village where they're unsuspecting. If the Vikings had done this, Tom, in Wessex, we would describe it as a massacre. We wouldn't say a battle and a heroic story. We'd say a horrendous massacre. And I think it is a horrendous massacre. The Cheyennes say that afterwards the women were divided up and turned into sex slaves. And the fact that Custer's own scouts tell this story as well, suggests to me, they're not colluding in it. And the scout didn't want to be named.
完全是一场大屠杀。我的意思是，它有妇女和儿童。它有一个毫无防备的村庄。如果维京人做了这件事，汤姆，你知道，在威塞克斯，我们会把它描述为一场大屠杀。我的意思是，它有妇女和儿童。它有一个毫无防备的村庄。如果维京人做了这件事，汤姆，在威塞克斯，我们会把它描述为一场大屠杀。我们不会说这是一场战斗和一个英雄故事。我们会说这是一场可怕的大屠杀。我认为这是一场可怕的大屠杀。夏延人说，事后妇女们被瓜分并变成了性奴隶。事实上，卡斯特自己的侦察兵也讲述了这个故事，这向我表明，他们并没有串通一气。而且那个侦察兵不想透露姓名。
Yeah. It totally makes sense. It's not beyond the realms of fantasy. We know that Custer, as you said earlier, he's got a very high sex drive. He has clearly let his wife down in some way repeatedly. It's claimed, again, much later, but who knows knows that he gives her a child yeah who's called what was it yellow bird i think that's not sufficiently well attested yeah but i do think undoubtedly there was very very bad behavior after this massacre so actually at the time
是的。这完全说得通。这并非超出了幻想的范畴。我们知道卡斯特，正如你之前所说，他的性欲非常强。他显然多次在某种程度上辜负了他的妻子。有人声称，虽然是很久以后，但谁知道呢，他给了她一个孩子，是的，叫什么来着，黄鸟，我想那没有得到充分的证实，是的，但我确实认为毫无疑问，在这场大屠杀之后确实发生了非常非常糟糕的行为，所以实际上在当时，
although there's lots of criticism custer's chiefs are very pleased with him. They regard him as having completely redeemed himself. Well, because he has got around the problem of how do you pin down Indian opponents and demonstrate your power as the US military? Because they haven't been able to escape. No. They haven't been able to just kind of move out. And so this idea, which Custer demonstrates, that you can firstly divide your forces up and kind of hammer an anvil. So,
尽管有很多批评，但卡斯特的上司对他非常满意。他们认为他已经完全救赎了自己。好吧，因为他解决了如何锁定印第安对手并展示美国军事力量的问题。因为他们没能逃脱。不。他们没能就这样离开。所以这个想法，卡斯特展示了，你可以首先分散你的部队，进行锤砧战术。所以，
you know, multiple prongs, crush them, nuts between a nutcracker. And secondly, that you use women and children as hostages. These are both developments that Custer has patented. And, you know, he will undoubtedly remember that these were effective tactics. ends. The dog soldiers are completely beaten. The Cheyenne have basically been crushed. Western Kansas and Southern Nebraska have been cleared. The railroads can continue. Settlement can continue. General Sheridan is very pleased with Custer. And actually, lots of people say, you know what? The Indian Wars, so-called, are over. Because in March 1869, despite Custer having endorsed his opponent, Ulysses S. Grant becomes the next president of the United States. And Grant says, listen, it's a new era in our dealing with the people of the plains. He says he gives control of an Indian policy. It's always
你知道，多管齐下，像胡桃夹子一样压碎他们。其次，你利用妇女和儿童作为人质。这些都是卡斯特专利的发展。而且，你知道，他无疑会记得这些是有效的战术。结束了。狗战士被彻底击败了。夏延人基本上被粉碎了。堪萨斯州西部和内布拉斯加州南部已经被清理干净。铁路可以继续。定居可以继续。谢里登将军对卡斯特非常满意。实际上，很多人说，你知道吗？所谓的印第安战争结束了。因为在1869年3月，尽管卡斯特支持了他的对手，尤利西斯·S·格兰特成为了美国下一任总统。格兰特说，听着，这是我们与平原人民打交道的新时代。他说他把印第安政策的控制权交给了，它总是
described as his Quaker policy because he gives loads of Quakers, Methodists, sort of evangelical Protestants. He says, you know, you sort out the Indian policy, spread the word, you know, let us have a more enlightened, liberal approach. People will remember from the previous episode that Appomattox, when General Lee had surrendered on behalf of the Confederacy, he had said to Grant's secretary, who was a Native American, he had said, oh, at least there's one American here. This guy is Eli Parker, who is a Seneca from New York. And Grant now says to Eli Parker, you are my new commissioner for Indian affairs. You are an Indian.
被描述为他的贵格会政策，因为他给了很多贵格会教徒、卫理公会教徒、某种福音派新教徒。他说，你知道，你们来处理印第安政策，传播福音，你知道，让我们采取一种更开明、更自由的方法。人们会记得上一集，当李将军代表邦联投降时，他曾对格兰特的秘书，一位美洲原住民说，哦，至少这里有一个美国人。这个人是伊莱·帕克，他是来自纽约的塞内卡人。格兰特现在对伊莱·帕克说，你是我的印第安事务新专员。你是一个印第安人。
You know, let's have a new era of friendship and cooperation. And Grant, in his inaugural address and speeches generally, he says, let us have friendship. We will build reservations. We'll have reservations, big reservations, lots of great facilities, lots of food, supplies, where the people of the plains can be integrated and we can live in friendship. When I said, let us have peace, I meant it. I don't like riding over and shooting these poor savages. I want to conciliate them and make them peaceful citizens. You can't thrash people so that they will love you. Even though they're Indians, you will make enemies friends by kindness.
你知道，让我们开启一个友谊与合作的新时代。格兰特在他的就职演说和一般演讲中说，让我们拥有友谊。我们将建立保留地。我们将有保留地，大的保留地，很多很棒的设施，很多的食物、补给，平原人民可以在那里被融合，我们可以生活在友谊中。当我说，让我们和平相处时，我是认真的。我不喜欢骑马过去射杀这些可怜的野蛮人。我想安抚他们，让他们成为和平的公民。你不能通过鞭打人们来让他们爱你。即使他们是印第安人，你也会通过仁慈把敌人变成朋友。
Well, basically he wants to treat them like immigrants, make them Americans. Assimilate them, yeah. Dissolve them in the melting pot. Whether they want to be dissolved, of course, is a very different matter. Yeah. But at the time,
好吧，基本上他想把他们当作移民来对待，让他们成为美国人。同化他们，是的。把他们溶解在熔炉里。当然，他们是否想被溶解，那是另一回事。是的。但在当时，
everybody says, hurrah, the peace policy, the new age has dawned. It's woke Indian fighting. Yeah. The end of our Indian wars, the hatchet will be buried
每个人都说，万岁，和平政策，新时代已经到来。这是觉醒的印第安战斗。是的。我们的印第安战争结束了，战斧将被埋葬
from Oregon to Texas. So maybe, Tom, there'll be nothing for Custer to do. But, as we'll discover next time, things will work out very differently because next time we will be plunging into the world of the Lakota Sioux and we'll be meeting some
从俄勒冈到德克萨斯。所以也许，汤姆，卡斯特将无事可做。但是，正如我们下次将发现的那样，事情的发展将非常不同，因为下次我们将深入拉科塔苏族的世界，我们将见到一些
absolutely rip-roaring characters, won't we? Crazy Horse, Red Cloud and Crazy Horse. All the lads. Yes. And the pace will quicken as we move forward towards the Titanic showdown at the Little Bighorn. But wouldn't it be lovely if there was some way in which a very keen listener could actually hear that episode right now? So rather than just kind of sitting in an army base and all that kind of thing, instead you could gallop across the prairie and dominic the
绝对轰动的人物，不是吗？疯马，红云和疯马。所有的小伙子们。是的。随着我们向小大角战役的泰坦尼克式对决迈进，步伐将会加快。但是，如果有一个非常热心的听众现在就能听到那一集，那该多好啊？所以与其只是坐在一个军事基地里做那些事情，不如你可以骑马穿过草原，多米尼克，
amazing thing is and this will come as a complete revelation to regular listeners there is a way of doing that there is you can go to the rest is history.com and subscribe and you can get all the episodes there and a whole host of other benefits as well so huge excitement it's actually even better than joining a cheyenne warrior society the dog soldiers yeah but if you don't want to join up that that's absolutely fine. Yeah. You twiddle your thumbs in some Cans and Forks. You'll get them in the long run.
令人惊奇的事情是，这对常客来说将是一个完全的启示，有一种方法可以做到这一点，你可以去therestishistory.com订阅，你可以在那里获得所有的剧集以及其他许多好处，所以非常令人兴奋，这实际上比加入夏延战士协会，那些狗战士还要好。是的，但如果你不想加入，那绝对没问题。是的。你在某个堪萨斯叉路口转动你的拇指。从长远来看，你会得到的。
Yeah. So lots more to come. Hope you're enjoying it. And we'll be back either straight away or very soon with The Sioux. See you then. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。所以还有很多内容。希望你喜欢它。我们将很快或不久后回来讲述苏族的故事。到时候见。再见。再见。再见。拉开娱乐的帷幕，我们告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的提前购买权。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。